I remember when I was a kid a man told
me he's like Grant patience is a virtue
and I looked at him and said are you
trying to get a head start on me because
that's what it sounds like that reminds
me of how many people say money won't
make you happy rich people aren't happy
why is this whole Rich topic so
sensitive to so many people why is it so
many people the moment you say Rich
wealthy get rich get wealthy you get all
this negativity around being rich rich
people aren't happy rich people are
dysfunctional rich people are greedy
rich people are selfish you've heard all
that money won't make you happy why all
the disdain why the hate why the
criticism for the wealthy I'm not
talking about people that inherit
through their money I'm talking about
people that worked from nothing and
created an Empire and created true
wealth that you can't possibly get rid
of in a lifetime people that will
actually create so much wealth they'll
leave it for generations to come the
duponts the Fords the carnegies bad
people or did they do something really
big look when I talk about getting rich
I'm talking about you tapping into your
full potential not just financially but
in all areas of your life my family I'm
rich my company I'm rich my finances I'm
rich my other businesses are rich not
just because they have money but because
they're rich in ideas rich in great
people rich in energy resources and
creativity and if you don't want to get
rich please don't blame other people
that want to hey it's Evan Carmichael
and I make these videos because in my
first business I quit on my business
partner I was making 300 bucks a month
and I didn't have the motivation to keep
going and the thing that got me through
was studying the stories of
entrepreneurs who've had massive success
and I hope that in sharing these stories
with you you find a motivation to keep
going and if I'm being honest I still
need the source for myself today too so
today let's learn from one of the best
Grant Cardone and get some incredible
motivation enjoy
whoever is most certain wins the sales
game okay you want to write this down it
is not about trust it is about certainty
whoever is most certain wins the sales
game certainty wins the sales game if
he's certain he's not going to do it he
ain't gonna do it if I'm certain he is
going to do it certainly wins the game
whoever's most certain wins the game
Elena was less certain about marrying me
than I was certain about her marrying me
had nothing to do with love
okay you don't need love to close the
deal you need certainty
half of the people that have done
business with me said they would never
do business with me half the people that
follow me today did not like me when
they first saw me one of the number one
comments we get is man the first time I
saw one of your videos I hated your guts
you're showing up they changed your mind
how many of you know they're saying you
can never change a bad first impression
how many know they're saying it's
completely not true some of my best
customers have come from Bad First
Impressions I can't control a first
impression some of you came in the room
and didn't like me today when you walked
in here nothing to do with me it's about
you having a bad day okay now let me
flip the page and give you a little
certainty you see how you wrote it down
this is how I would write it down number
one you greet the customer number two
you qualify the customer you agree hey
that's how long our greeting takes by
the way if you spend more than two
seconds on a greeting Thomas great to
have you here appreciate you coming all
right that's it it's not about the
weather it's not about politics people
spend so much time in the greeting but
said I need to remember that the
qualification process is designed to
figure out what to show him and how to
close it this is a report building step
I'm taking interest in why he's here why
do people buy things
solve a problem that's the only reason
anybody on the planet ever buys any
product
to solve a problem demonstrate the
product make a proposal close follow-up
those are six steps what are they great
qualify demonstrate propose close
follow-up did I miss anything everybody
try this great number one great number
one green number two qualify
three demonstrate
four make a proposal make a proposal
make a proposal
five close the deal
follow up that's it man like if you
can't remember them you can't do them if
you got a thousand dollars I would like
just keep you know keep investing
yourself until you got another thousand
okay and and then invest in yourself you
know now you got 2 000 investing you go
go go you should start making money
faster at some point you should start
like every time you make an investment
in yourself if I put fuel in my car it's
supposed to take me further right right
so if I invest in myself then look you
know there's things I bought that I
didn't get a return on right away
but I didn't quit investing in a course
or a workshop or training or education
because it didn't work for your health
or I spent 17 years going to school none
of it was any good for me but it did
teach me it did teach me how to go to
school
you know how to study how to study how
to go there how to how to complete a
course like I completed college I think
you just got to keep investing in you
until like oh now I'm making three
thousand dollars okay boom reinvest all
that again but what we do is we start
taking it off the table right and we say
when we don't invest it so I think
people just need to get on that that
cycle of like okay I'm gonna keep
repeating this activity I'm going to
reinvest the money in myself go to the
workshop or whatever Monday I got to be
hustling again until okay now I got four
thousand dollars okay now I got five
thousand now the income's starting to
pick up income has to pick up in the
income should be an indication that
whatever you're learning is helping you
that's interesting until one day you're
like okay I have more money here than I
can actually invest in myself I can't
like there's nothing I can go to to get
rid of this money you need to get rid of
that money though if I did it all over
again today I would the first thing I
would learn today
is the money game
I believe this is the single most
important thing your staff can learn
your Executives can learn uh your your
financial person your CEO by the way the
person your CFO your your Chief
Financial Officer they don't even know
anything about finances what they
actually actually let me change that
it's not that they don't know anything
about finances what they know is
actually one of the people holding you
back
[Music]
uh
the uh kpi
the return the Met we're not getting a
Roi on this investment
the return on investment is terrible
this is not a good return
you know like like you got to understand
they're counting money
they're not creating it
right so our expenses are too high
we need to reduce our expenses and we
pay sales people too much money
in our in our company number one most
important protected group in the company
is the sales team
I think we gonna overpay anybody if we
overpay anybody it is the guy and the
gal that is going out bringing in the
kill
that's right
okay so the income line man this money
thing this money game this is this is
how financial statement Works income
expenses
net
okay
I I screwed the whole deal up
I spent more time on this line than I
did on this line
how many of you know people do this
reduce the expenses reduce the expenses
reduce the expenses reduce the expenses
how
men you go to zero
how high can you fly
see I can take this number to Infinity
I can only take this number to zero
everybody agree so I spend today 95
percent of my time on income and less
than five percent of my time on expenses
so you're you're your financial officer
is spending all their time on what
uh this expense and that expense and
where this went and where that went I
saw Brandon the other night we went to
dinner with Brandon and some of his
clients so that it's very very special
Elite clients and
um we were having dinner and and Brandon
when the bill came and Brandon picked up
the bill and and he took a picture of it
I said why are you taking a picture of
it well to send this to the to whoever
collects history because once it's an
expense is history
everybody agree
now have you ever gotten rich off of
History
and that's what accountants do they
record history something that was done
where's your where's your future going
to come from
income is the future right so I spend 95
percent of my time on two things
marketing
and income
and if I spend too much big deal I'm
gonna go find this is the solution to
all my problems marketing and income
everybody agree
I'm gonna go expand Netflix Amazon Apple
Google dude they don't worry about their
expenses they're like how much can we
spend how many people can we hire how
big can we get how long can we bleed and
one day we'll own the world a lot of
people don't get it who I am because
you know because I'm Brash and I'm
Bodacious and I do and I probably just
say things wrong
and
I don't I don't really think through how
I'm going to say something I just say it
and then let it the chips fall where
they fall but
I want the people around me doing well
like I don't wanna I'm not the guy I'm
here by myself today but most of the
time I'm rolling with a crew I want them
all doing well I want those guys making
money
I don't want people suffering around me
I want people
I know that when we go someplace they
want to pay the bill too
I mean the wine when the wine list comes
out I know the guys I work with are like
hey Grant whatever whatever you want bro
just get it on me
everybody wants to pay that big check so
I think I I you know the weight of 10x
is to make sure you're doing well and 10
other people not other people are doing
well that's the big 10x
you know you fix your house and nine
other houses on the street or you don't
fix the houses you you get the
neighborhood in a condition where
everybody's fixing their own house and
the value of the neighborhood comes up
and then the schools and then you reach
out to next Friday night and the schools
are better and then the firemen are
getting taken care of the police or
maybe we don't even need a police
department anymore because everybody's
so freaking sane now people aren't
killing each other
and not hate on each other not beating
the wives
like the the amount of dumb stuff we do
and that I've done when I'm when I when
I'm working when I'm on course when I'm
like when I'm you know I'm not bothering
other people
I think if everybody just got more
productive on
fulfilling their own potential nobody
would have time for Wars drugs you
wouldn't even have time to go find a
drug dealer be like I'm sorry oh yeah
you know I'll get it later but right now
I got this if I can make it
I have not collaborated with other
people I didn't come for money I had no
connections
I have refused to like not be myself and
yet somehow I
made it
and so the one thing is like if you just
don't quit if you don't quit if you
refuse to quit you will not fail one
people should be invested in the
beginning and just in themselves every
chance you get to to go to something
that could possibly help you has a if it
has a one percent chance of even adding
to the value you have in your spend the
money
don't sit on money money's useless
so
if you have five thousand dollars left
in your account I would spend the whole
five thousand on yourself
when you spend money on yourself you're
going to start getting better at
whatever you're doing if you just keep
doing it if you keep spinning it just
because you spent it once and it didn't
work go do it again and then again and
then again that that has been one thing
in my life like if you ask me hey what's
one thing I always invest in me first
not the business not the business not
the real estate me my condition how am I
doing am I around the right people am I
listening like I don't care what it is
dinner lunch Charities I just go to
anything anything where I think there's
other people doing well you know the 10x
rule is based on look your the goals
people are setting are too small you
know I want to get a good job
I want to get married I want to be happy
the goals are wrong
and I hate to tell somebody their goals
are wrong but I'm just I don't know that
your goals are wrong you know I know
that my goals have always been too small
everything I have done in my life
has not been
I have underestimated what I could do
every time I've gotten to where I got I
was like dang did I could that wasn't
even that hard like it wasn't even that
difficult and it got easier as I got rid
of the people that said I couldn't do it
mostly it wasn't really people saying I
couldn't do it it was mostly people
saying dude but why do you need to they
were requesting why I need to right so
if your kid decides man he wants to be
you don't want to be an astronaut he's
like I don't want to be an astronaut
dude
I want to be the guy that creates the
company
that sends
millions of people to another planet see
he's like why would I want to be the
pilot dude he's just another worker I
want to be I want to be the Elon Musk
that figured it out right so so and and
you'll be like man just be happy to be
an astronaut right but but he's got a
bigger dream and we should all that's
the first thing I would tell people look
whatever you think
your dream is
one you gotta add money you got it
people people are having goals and
dreams about money you know there's all
these quotes on the internet a goal
without a date is merely a wish that
will never happen whatever dude a goal
without money attached to it okay is
something that will never be
accomplished because there is no goal on
this planet that doesn't require money
including happy to be happy
you need money
and and uh your audience is I'd love to
see their comments like you cannot be
happy without money the only way you can
be happy and broke is to be insane yeah
because the only an insane person would
say yeah dude we're all good I don't
know where food's coming from tonight
but I'm happy that means well I don't
know where you how you're paying for
your drugs
because you can't be happy knowing I
can't pay for the next meal it's just
it's it's it's mentally impossible so
you got to be in the morning you got to
be looking
so you got to get
you got to have cash okay do not use the
last two as an excuse not to do a deal
shame on you
if you leave here and you keep blaming I
don't have the money and I don't have
the bank you don't need the money and
you don't need the bank you need the
damn deal to me the interest only loan
is a really great loan to get because
because you have a stable stable one of
your greatest expenses is now stabilized
completely meaning the debt will not go
up so if my my debt payments are 400
Grand a year they're never going to
change my taxes will keep changing my
expenses will keep changing employee
payroll will keep changing I need to
secure and stabilize as much as I can
so interest only is not really about the
asset class as much as it is about the
amount of Leverage you use anyone anyone
can get
when as long as you're working with the
right lender and the size that a deal is
right almost anyone can get an
interestingly loan
so if you get down to 50 percent you're
probably good
you just got to ask your bank like that
the lady yesterday said oh we don't do
interest only guarantee they do interest
only
and you shouldn't be scared scared of
interest only
because what is principle and interest
anyway principle pay down is like a two
percent a point and a half pay down over
10 years over 10 years you're going to
pay down your debt maybe 15 percent
so rather than me putting 65 down I pay
50 down right now and it's interestingly
the whole time
all I'm doing is prepaying my pay down
to get the deal you need a commitment
you got to have a commitment when you
leave here you got to be like okay man
I'm gonna take my money how many of you
got cash in the bank right now
you have cash in the bank because you
don't have confidence in these deals
I don't have cash in the bank because I
trust my real estate more than I do my
cash how many you got a 401k good that's
because you do not understand the value
of Real Estate
because if you understood the value of
real estate the way I do you would not
have a 401k
that you can't access for 30 years
how many of you got equity in your home
excellent
and that just shows me that you do not
have complete confidence in the game
that I'm telling you right now because
if you had complete confidence in what
I'm doing you would not have equity in
your home you probably wouldn't even
have a damn home
you'd have your money sitting in 161
units somewhere paying you a check every
month
to make your house payment that you owe
money on you guys are just getting
started
you're not going to start right here
you're going to start down there okay
probably in another city another town I
grew up in Lake Charles Louisiana no
money raised by a single mother I was in
debt at 25 years old the first thing
that I had to do in my life was not
learn a new skill
first thing I had to do to get my life
moving in the right direction was
self-development
it is vital it was vital for me that I
improved myself and I could start
depending upon me I had to show up every
day with some rituals some disciplines
and start getting myself to trust me not
trust others but trust myself to do the
right thing every day one of the things
that I started doing was beating the Sun
up every morning
I'm gonna beat that son up every morning
so that I had the discipline and the
control of over my life
so I knew hey before that thing pops I'm
gonna pop I'm gonna get out of bed
depend on myself get up at the same time
every day and for me that time
regardless of where I was was beat that
son up no matter where I am I'm gonna
beat that thing up so it gives me a
sense of control over my own life second
thing I had to start cleaning up my life
and my friends and my environment when I
was younger between 15 and 25 I was
doing crazy stuff in my life
wasting my weekends I have the same
weekends or for the week
I was drinking fooling around with a
bunch of bad things bad people making
poor choices at 25 years old I cleaned
it all up quit going to those places
quit using those things quit hanging out
with people that did not have ethics and
discipline in their life that weren't
committed to the same things that I was
I wanted to build something in my life I
wanted to become someone and to do that
to become someone in the eyes of the
world the first thing I had to do was
become someone I could depend on so put
some things together three or four
things you can do every day to start the
day kick start your day get going in
your day to give you a sense of respect
for yourself accomplishment for yourself
look just beating that scent up every
morning gives me the sense of
accomplishment that I did what I said
said I was going to do that I woke up
when I said I would wake up and I start
building respect for myself start
believing in myself so that I can go out
into the world and maybe maybe maybe
today maybe today when I go into this
meeting that I'm dressed for maybe
they'll believe in me as much as I
believe in me and that'll show up in a
contract a deal maybe even some money I
used to listen to guys that were
Millionaires and they were like when I
look back now I'm like oh they were all
like don't get bigger bigger is not
better flying to the radar uh you know
it it what matters is how much you make
how much you net how much you keep save
your money everything all those guys as
there were two and three and four
million even some guys that were worth
five and ten they're all about
contraction that's right they're trying
to save conservative because when you
start talking to these other dudes I'm
not talking about myself now when I get
around guys they're over 600 million
800.
4 billion they never talk about that do
they think my money's jump money they're
like that that's not money right there
dude look quit looking at your notes
okay what do you want to do here
it's in my notes nobody's in you okay
what do you want what does Tommy need to
do
is making 400 Grand worried about
somebody that's no good
okay where does Tommy need to go
screw the mechanics okay where you've
been screw where you've been
dude where where are you in the right
vehicle you have to change
[Music]
okay where you've been means nothing
none of this the the chick that you
hired in New Orleans what you did last
year did none of it
no no you just want to skip now dude you
just want to drop the pass
it doesn't matter okay so my goal for
you I don't know if it's your goal but
I'm hearing you say some of this
let's just go to number one in your
Market you know I hear people all the
time complain about their job they don't
want to have a job I'm like man you have
to love your job
if you don't love your job how are you
going to go start a business and have
people that work for you that don't hate
their job
it's a gift to be able to have a job
like if you can smile I really believe
this if I can smile throughout my life
even when I'm eating [ __ ]
like yeah okay what else you got you
know I was telling Elena she was down
there boxing this morning and with
Javier and
man she her cooks are getting awesome
and she had this look on her face right
I said look you got to smile when you do
that kick you gotta smile when you punch
you got to smile when you get punched
because when you can smile when you're
eating [ __ ] and taking a punch
when things are not going well when
you're terrified and you can keep
smiling through it
I think I think Roosevelt said or maybe
it was Churchill said hey look when
you're going through hell skip
move run
okay and have a smile on your face like
it doesn't bother you
and and you become dangerous to other
people when you can eat [ __ ] you're
humble enough to say yeah okay I'll do
the dishes okay I'll sweep the floors
Advantage is a multi-family investing
number one more doors the easier to
manage and fund the project it's easier
it's just an easier deal two units
harder to manage than 22 yards because
the bigger you get the further away you
can get from it two units you need a
manager that manager is going to charge
you at least 10 or 12 percent somebody's
got to manage the property somebody's
going to answer the phone calls four
grand a month somebody's gonna want at
least 400 bucks a month to take the
[ __ ] phone calls number two all
units one location reduces management
activity number three one Closing one
property I could buy one deal get 300
units you buy 300 houses you need 300
closings four one financial statement
300 units fits on One Financial State
one duplex fits in the same financial
statement number five produce enough
Revenue to hire management team
Advantage is a multi-family you can hire
management team number six producer
enough cash flow to invest in capex
capex circle this word it means
expenditure on the capital of the
building meaning the Capital
Improvements of the building roof floors
cabinets how many have done cabinets
before use Graphics the guy that wraps
your cars in your city say hey come wrap
my cabinets I like things done quickly I
bought the house Elena's not there I
call my rap guy come in here man
don't sand it don't paint it wrap it
boom it was done in the afternoon number
seven more units allow more amenities
two units you do not have a swimming
pool you do not have security you do not
have a gym 300 units you got a gym you
got security you got trees you got
picnics you got dog parks you got great
stuff you got Gates I have properties
where the pool at the apartment building
is nicer than the pool that we have at
our house and Elena's like where are you
going I said I'm going to the pool at
the apartment building I got some
apartment buildings that's I mean I'd
move in there
because they got action everywhere and
the bigger the deal is the easier it is
to add value and spend money on it right
if I'm gonna spend some money man I
could spin it cross it across a bunch of
stuff rather than two units why do I
love real estate why does Real Estate
build Financial Freedom number one
protects your capital okay if if I buy
this deal is the money is the money is
the cash the money that I put down to
buy this deal is the money gonna be
worth more or less in the future
another cash
is worth less in the future what about
this building
only by the way not all buildings are
worth more in the future
if the building's in a good location and
it stays occupied and rents can rise it
will be more worth more money in the
future okay I want you to be sure you
guys understand this not all real estate
goes up in value
you think it's good to be liquid
I would encourage everybody in the room
to stay illiquid
Wall Street wants you to be liquid the
banks want you to be liquid okay the
courts want you to be liquid your lawyer
wants you to be liquid
because as long as you're liquid
they can grab it from you
you understand like if you're liquid
you're never going to file for
bankruptcy
you'll never ever tap into a bankruptcy
option
if you don't have a lot of debt you
can't use the bankruptcy courts
which are put there to protect you from
losing everything
now I've never filed bankruptcy because
my real estate got me through all the
hard times 2000 2010 2020 covid my
Apartments got me through when our other
business hurt despite what you guys saw
on the news by the way when rental
apartment rentals we're going to go to
84 70 the world was going to go to hell
we collected more rent during covid than
we collected the previous year
did you even have the courage to borrow
money because if you don't have the
courage to borrow money you will never
have net worth and you will never have a
good credit score everybody agree
and you don't need to worry about your
credit score how many how many of you
you've been told you need to raise your
credit score in order to be free on this
planet no you need net worth
to be free on this planet excuse
completely made up
nobody needs a pair of fendies and my
wife does not need six inch heels
everybody agree
okay you don't need all that stuff
but we made it up so you got a product
you got a service and now we can sell it
to people but you do need a place to
live and you need water and you need
food everybody agree I gotta have
something over my head to shelter me
from the
the exterior I need some food and I need
some water those things will not change
no matter what happens with the internet
Amazon cannot replace housing
it can replace where you get your books
so when I'm watching Blackstone take
okay why are they taking currency
converting it to buildings
okay they take and write a check they
wrote a check for the entire thing no
debt 10 000 houses they then waited
filled it up with renters I'm watching
this in 2008 filled it up with renters
and then what they did was they refined
the entire process
sold it as bonds
to your grandmother
they pay your grandmother like two and a
half to three and a half percent
okay your grandmother's so happy that
every quarter she gets a little freaking
bang
they probably worked with AIG to do this
or State Farm or All-State or Prudential
or MetLife or New York Life insurance
companies back most of my real estate
transactions
okay because real estate real estate is
is that thing that an insurance company
can use to depend on to pay for your
life benefits it's not about getting the
right answers about being able to use
the information in the right situation
and so you have to go into a situation
knowing something's going to be stable
particularly in an environment where
there's a lot of variables and we live
in an environment right now with a lot
of variables with covid the mass the
election coming who knows who there's a
million different things going on out
there you cannot you cannot add
another variable to that many variables
so the thing that you need to do is you
have to be the stable
person in an environment where there's a
lot of craziness going on I had so many
people tell me well it depends it
depends on the situation no dude you you
need to be the same person every time
regardless of the situation
because if you try to change to every if
you try that's the problem with this
whole adapting thing
if you're going to adapt to every
situation that happens in life you'll
never become anything
because you'll just be a chameleon one
second then a tiger the next Second and
then a kitty cat the next Second and
then it roadkill the next
[Music]
and that this disparity in America
particularly in America and around the
world the disparity between the the
people that have something and everybody
else is getting bigger and bigger if you
don't like the way that is
if you don't like the way that game's
working out you need to improve your
skill set so that you can go get yours
for you and your family because it's out
there
I'm just telling you the the
opportunities out there is whether you
want to open your eyes be conscious the
whole time go look at it and figure out
how do you get your share of the of the
American dream just because you're great
doesn't mean you don't want money in
fact the greater you are the more money
you're going to want so if you want
great people
I hear companies always talk about I
can't find great people because you
don't pay them anything man right so
like if I if I give you file for you 700
Grand right now can you swim
yeah you any good I'm okay yeah so if I
offer you 700 Grand right now say hey
dude you got to go swim after that boat
you got to catch it look you're not
going to worry about how cold the water
is your water's probably freezing ass
cold right you're gonna you're gonna if
you're Money Motivated hmm okay you're
gonna fly in there but but let's say I
put 700 grand out there and say whoever
gets to the boat first
exactly well what Trace exactly what
would you do it would you do it probably
I think anyone in the anyone in the
world would do it I don't know unless
you're a billionaire and you're like
yeah then 700 you're not motivated by
seven exactly right you'd want more than
700 yeah you'd be like yeah I'll do it
but you know what I know billionaires
would actually be the first people to
hit the water exactly because they
understand money they understand man
it's worth me paying that price to get
the 700 because they know what to do
with 700 a lot of people are not Money
Motivated because they simply don't know
what to do with money every time they
get it they actually lose it hey I
always tell you guys when you're picking
real estate out
make sure
that you never compromise
location okay look at this this location
right here some of you been
jabbing on me because oh Grant Cardone
doesn't take his own advice he went and
bought a house of Malibu he says not to
buy a house uh number one this is not a
house this is a
some art
located in one of the most popular
places in the country
and certainly in the state of California
this is beautiful Carbon Beach
Frontage
on one of the most desirable beaches in
Malibu
I'm saying this as humbly as I can like
on my guys look if you ever get a chance
in your life I'm not just bragging you
I'm just trying to show you don't
compromise location ever
the moment you compromise location you
can fix a lot of things I can fix the
paint I can fix the interior this
interior of this house is very very
dated
some people will like the cedar shake
the cottage look the some people will
like that color not like the color the
doors and windows are dated they
probably need to be changed pool at some
point needs to be updated it's 15 years
old some people will be all right some
people be like I don't like it it's just
a lap pool but it's 75 feet 75 feet of a
lap pull on Carbon Beach with neighbors
that are just on every major list and
it's just one super super super
desirable little spot in the universe so
when you're picking real estate doesn't
matter how big it is this house happens
to be 10 000 square feet
Interiors three-car garage
two two stories sits up on caissons they
go 60 feet deep into the sand and it uh
the granite
to provide it with a space it's got a 75
foot lap pool
on
kosher I guess
I just can't build it again
tried to build this again it would take
probably five years if you could get it
approved probably would not get 10 000
square feet approved again
would not get the pool
approved
and just a fantastic fantastic location
so for all of you that are out there
hearing me oh Grant Cardone don't take
his own advice you're right man I mean
I'm telling you I would not
if I was on the come up just trying to
get my game on just getting started I
wouldn't go buy a house it doesn't
provide my best friend cash flow if it
doesn't have cash flow what am I I gotta
fund it
this house actually could provide me
with cash flow and but if it didn't the
location's so ridiculous if I do the
right things with the interior and the
colors and the cedar shake the doors and
windows if I update this pool a little
bit
do the right things with the stone
furnace it on the interior in a way that
it should be
there's a real good chance
I make money on this house now you know
what I paid because it's been posted all
over the Internet what I paid for the
house when Real Deal posted it
in the Wall Street Journal
some of you like oh my God he overpaid
for this house how could this guy pay
that much money for this house
what do you think I'm going to sell this
house for in the future
150 feet there's three other homes on
Carbon Beach that have 150 feet on the
ocean none of it by the way is elevated
none of it most of it is down on the
sand you got Larry Ellison down the
street Michael Milken I mean these are
these are super super super wealthy
families Larry Ellison has one home his
son has building a brand new home that
they say will sell for 150 million if he
ever sells it
uh Michael milken's home they say is
worth a hundred and a half
stretch if you're going to do it stretch
and get the best possible location you
can I made this mistake my first three
homes I made the mistake
believing I'm gonna buy for less in a
great neighborhood I knew I knew to buy
in a great neighborhood but I I was
scared to pay the extra money to be in
that little pocket of that neighborhood
where the location was literally
Irreplaceable
so if you're buying a house this year
you're buying an apartment or you're
buying an office building or you're
buying uh
retail or storage maybe storage less
okay make sure you get
that kind of location that's
Irreplaceable people say the dumbest
things it could be family it could be
your wife your husband it could be a a
mom a dad a uncle an aunt it could be
your kids coming from school people say
what they think and what they think will
be what they say and what they say and
think often enough long enough
reinforced enough I promise you will be
what they do okay so look at some of the
dumb things you say like this here's one
dumb thing people say
Time Heals all things
really you get a splinter in your foot
and you don't pull the splinter out you
don't look at it confront it and say I
gotta pull that little booger out I
gotta pull that little splinter out if
you just leave it there you might get
used to it yeah you'll get used to it 30
years goes by you still got a splinter
in your foot who knows that splinter
gets into your bloodstream goes to your
heart spikes your heart kills you time
does not heal all things folks you know
what heals all things taking a look at
it Having the courage to look at it hey
what happened to me how did I screw up
here what what hurt or what pain or what
happened that I had a loss I see people
go through life with all these losses
unwilling to look at them all crippled
by the time they get older not old but
they looking old because they believe
that time heals look Time Heals when you
confront it when you look at it when you
pull the splinter out and take
responsibility for it don't believe
everything you believe you know what I'm
saying because some of the ideas you got
they just dumb and dumb things will
cause you to do dumb things well yeah I
can tell you for me like I was always
scared of money you know and and I was
terrified of it so so like if you look
at still today like I look at the bill
of everything
it's a bill of everything if something
calls something I want to know how much
it was
and so like how much is it like I'm
gonna ask that question whether whether
it matters or not
um it doesn't matter where I get in my
life I don't think I'm ever going to be
free of how much was that how much is
the dinner how much how much was dinner
how much was the tip how much was the
code how much was the jacket what did
you know me and Elena like Elena's like
it's gonna be fine man like look what
look at look a little look at what
you've done we cannot spend this and I'm
like how much was it
I want to know how much it was because
when I grew up do you had to know what
things cost and so the point your
question about money is is a terrifying
thing because
it's the one thing in life that
you know the NFL is not going to give me
the ball and and I'm never going to get
a chance to golf I can't win in those
environments but with money everybody
gets money it's the one place where
everybody gets it and now what do I do
and I can lose it now
so it's a terrifying concept like like
power you know very few of us ever ever
get any kind of influence or power right
once you get you're like hey what do I
do with this you know am I going to do
it I'm going to am I going to do the
right things with it and so I think
people withhold themselves because they
don't We're Not educated about money we
don't know where it comes from we have a
lot of misinformation about it our
parents terrified us you know money
doesn't grow in trees uh save your money
it'll save you all these these these
things our parents told us because they
were enamored
or are encumbered with the same kind of
liabilities around money right I don't
know how to get it
I don't know how to keep it
and the third the worst part that we're
all at is I don't know how to invest it
yeah so what I'll do is I'll some people
get good at getting it very few actually
fewer people at keeping it but probably
more than getting it there's probably a
big group in America that have learned
how to keep money because they're afraid
to lose it they don't want to invest it
they don't want to use it they don't
want to you know
um you know Kanye talks about this how
white people how white people save all
their money and they just keep it they
just store it like I had an uncle he
buried everything he ever made he went
in the backyard wow the other uncle was
was uh he was he was a guy that bought
he he worked hard very very frugal
Italian descent and he would uh buy real
estate but it was always buy low and
sell hot he actually never sold anything
but that was the concept Buy Low by the
cheapest lowest
get everything on a deal if there's food
stamps to be gotten you go get those
food stamps if there's a if there's a
government deal get it if it's Section 8
and the government will pay you pay it
so both these guys different kind of
mentalities were extremely Frugal my
other uncle was uh worked in a Refinery
he basically saved all his money paid
everything off got out of debt that was
their lifestyle my dad died when I was
10.
so he paid all his debt off had
everything paid and and so that's all I
had right everybody around me was like
get money keep it keep it don't use it
you know but but you should invest but
nobody ever learns that third one
and and so I think we're just a bunch of
people walking around terrified of this
this apparent apparency of it's scarce
right and it's not mm-hmm
and and you know it's not there's
nothing scarce about it and you know I'm
always keeping it real with you what has
happened to our country that we make our
idols and our icons and our heroes
rappers and entertainers and ball
players and then we show discuss for a
businessman that can Bank 50 million a
year or 20 million a year what is wrong
look when a guy can go out and make
passive Investments great decisions
execute show tremendous discipline okay
and disconcert between good Investments
and bad Investments and then make 20
million or 30 million bucks pay three or
four million dollars in taxes three or
four million dollars to his Charities
his churches his community helps out
with groups of people
and we have discontent for the
businessman that's out there year after
year making great Investments great
decisions showing leadership in the
marketplace look that Marketplace out
there that economy is the most Savage
most difficult playing field in the
world to negotiate yet
who do we admire in our culture rock
stars look these guys got great skills
kid gets out of school makes 12 million
a first year and and we make posters of
them in sweatshirts and and you put
their kids in their jerseys what about
the business people that make our
economy work they pay the taxes that
make the schools work the churches work
that make the fire department the police
department because they pay taxes
because they're out there making great
Investments look admire business people
that are able to bank year after year
admire these people study them learn
from them don't be disgusted with them
and turn off anybody anybody that would
suggesting you that making money in this
country is Wrong look don't envy
business people admire them emulate them
learn from them particularly these guys
are doing it year after year after year
not just on income but on wealth
development because that's where you
need to be that's where you need to be
thinking that's the economy you want to
create for yourself your family your
household and your future when you start
looking when you go from a doing a three
million dollar deal where I started a I
did my first deal was 1.9 million to
looking at Billion Dollar Deals you're
going to take the same trajectory I
promise you I'm blessing you guys right
now this is what you're gonna do you're
going to start with little deals if you
listen to me you'll skip those but you
can start there if you wanted to you
want to eat Cheerios you can okay
or you could just like hey let me go get
the good stuff right now I'm gonna I'm
gonna eat off the top of the shelf right
now you just got to have imagination
right and not be limited to like I don't
have the money I don't have the
connections I I'm not in the I'm not in
the environment I don't know these
people good well you're going to get to
know these people
if I know them you can know them
and and so so when we have this trapped
Equity I'm like I'm trying to do these
big deals and I'm like I don't have the
money to do them
so I want you to write this down
what do you have
not what you don't have
[Music]
what do you have right the question
needs to go from you know not I can't do
it to how can I do it not what I don't
have
what do I have
and or who has it so we basically made a
list who's got this money
okay without me selling my properties
because I do not want to sell my
properties
because if I sell my properties I'm just
going back to zero I could sell the
whole portfolio right now I'm just going
to go back to zero and have to start
over again I don't want to start from
zero I want to start I want to just add
to what I have right
so we made a list we started talking to
guys in The Brokerage business you've
got to get a mortgage broker this guy
pravesh is a mortgage broker how many
have we been through Ryan how many names
do you have pravesh eight or nine yeah
we're gonna last two years they never
rely on One on One Bank
or one lender
you want more lenders than you got kids
and wives and husbands
this polygamy
okay so we just start making a list of
lenders we started out with a I started
with a Regional Bank I started with a
local Bank San Diego National Bank in
San Diego they're out of business they
collapsed in 2010. they were taken down
by the federal government they were
replaced by another group the federal
government gave a group in Minneapolis
500 million dollars to buy the bank out
it's basically a takeover a hostile
takeover by the federal government
seizing property a guy the the guy that
owned the bank had 300 million he could
put in the bank to fund the bank in 2010
and the federal government said no
we're going to give 500 million dollars
to a guy in Minneapolis
to buy you out and it was Federal money
tax dollars your money
was funded to another guy the club
they took this other guy out I owed I
owed 50 million to the bank of San Diego
when the new bank came in the new bank
said you need to pay your loans off I'm
not gonna pay my loans off
yeah you're in violation you you have
technical default a technical default
I've never missed a payment in my life
oh yeah but the asset values because of
2008 have collapsed
so and your net worth has changed
and the world has changed I'm like yeah
and by the way because you pay us is why
we're here we know you can pay we know
you have money and I had a bunch of
money sitting in a bank account and they
wanted to grab that money that's what
they wanted
okay the guys that didn't have money
they never called them
and I learned in 2010 I'm like hey don't
have a bunch of money sitting around you
got money sitting around they're going
home get that money when [ __ ] goes to
when when the world goes to hell they go
after people that have money not people
that don't have money
you want debt
you want lots of it
so so when I had 50 million in debt what
I learned in 2010 was I don't have
enough debt I said the next time this
[ __ ] happens I might have two billion
dollars
I'm a sink a ship
okay I'm I'm gonna they're gonna have to
pay attention to me because if you're
not big enough they're not going to pay
attention too big to what exactly you
guys need to get too big to fail don't
hate on the system man don't hate the
game don't hate the player
learn the game and be a player
showing up means
showing up
you understand it doesn't mean you came
to work
for me showing up means I show up I've
been showing up since I was
25 years old man before that I wasn't
showing up
I was showing off
I was acting a fool being a fool
High School I didn't show up I went to
class I never showed up my body went in
the room see showing up doesn't mean you
got there showing up means you got there
and then you showed up again and then
you showed up again and then you showed
up again I mean she showed up for the
class she show up for the homework you
show up for the class you show up for
the homework you show up for the test
you freaking get a perfect grade means
you keep showing up to the next level
and I hear a lot of people talking about
showing up you know showing up is not
everything let me tell you something
showing up when you show up the right
way
Johnny you got to put your seatbelt on
you show up the right way when you show
up the right way
success showing up means you're looking
for deeper levels to show up to pay
attention
that's what I do every day every day I
come to work I'm like show up man show
up for every little problem show for
every little opportunity show up for
every little little new nuance
little angle little particle little
movement that's why I see all this stuff
why is that not cleaned up why is this
not cleaned up once somebody pick that
up
who's that new person here
hey are you feeling all right today how
many times have I asked you that before
you all right today I know it's the
little things
it's simple costs nothing to do this
show up you cost you nothing
and it makes all the difference man it's
showing up you'll see things that no one
else sees
and and you know the good news is
anybody can do this you just got to make
a commitment to show up you know and I
was aware at that moment how many times
in my life
I've I've woken up like not sure
I think it started happening for me
uh years ago like like
probably around 12 or 13. I didn't know
what to do every day what's what's today
going to bring maybe it's after watching
so much TV and eating so much sugar you
know I think our diets definitely have a
lot to do with all that
but look I want to give you something
today about how to get out of the funk
the funky Hawk dark
when I by the time I was 25 this thing
went on from 12 to 25 at 25 years old I
was in so much depression every day I
was using drugs alcohol
I was self-medicating constantly
making bad decisions I lived in a 275
uh
uh I mean I just remember how much it
was it was 275 dollars a month and every
other month I couldn't make the bill the
payment I was late
today I live in this joint right here
live up on the 33rd floor of this place
and
completely different life today than I
had then 25 I went to a treatment center
for 20 28 days for drug addiction I was
using drugs every day hated it
let me tell you something worse than
drugs it's how you feel about yourself I
hated myself every time I did a drug
every time I smoked weed every time
every time I did
any drug the moment I put the pill in my
mouth the weed to my mouth something in
my nose I hated myself
I never felt good
about using drugs
and so
by the time I was 25 I had been using
drugs for
10 years but my problems started before
that
my problems didn't start with the drugs
it started with my inability to manage
this
light grade chronic depression
this
for lack of better words this this idea
that I wasn't good enough this idea that
that uh
that um
I didn't love myself you know that that
you know my my mom gave my mom quit on
me my mom told me hey don't come around
here anymore my twin brother
pretty much
was done with me
my sisters both knew that I was in
trouble and were like oh my God you know
we're gonna get a call on him today
the people I worked with the principal
at the high school I went to said I
couldn't couldn't win dog catcher
in my 11th and 12th grade told my mom
that
my student
um my PE teacher said I would amount to
nothing I wrecked my car on my driver's
ed test I failed my driver's license
test I was fired from my first six jobs
wouldn't leave the sixth one dude I'm
telling you I was a loser
loser okay I'm telling you loser and I
didn't have to ask other people nobody
had to tell me I was a loser I knew I
was a loser
so look if you've ever been there I know
there's people watching this right now
maybe you don't even know who I am
you're like who's this dude talking
about himself you know
I've come from that where I was bankrupt
spiritually financially physically I
weighed 134 pounds that's 40 pounds less
than I weigh today
I was broken every way possible I didn't
have any money I was in debt
but worst the worst thing the worst of
the worst of the worst
was how I felt about myself
I got out of that treatment center and
the counselor told me on the way out of
the treatment center if you read my last
book be obsessed or be average it was
the first book that I really shared
anything about my life
of all seven of my books that that one
gives you a kind of a look inside my
life more than anything
and um maybe what I'll do is in this
maybe what I'll do is I'll have my guys
give you give you a
a a chapter that book free and um it's
not what I came here to give you I want
to do I do want to give you something
but maybe my guys could put a couple of
different links in here for you so
I got out of that treatment center and
the counselor said to me I think his
name was Philip I don't remember the guy
now I hated this guts then I still don't
think much of him he said to me God was
really confused
he was more confused than I was he said
now that I look back he said to me he
said to me he said hey if you leave here
if you leave here and you don't give up
you know because when you're there you
spill your guts tell them everything and
I told him I wanted to be rich and
famous and and help people and write
books and you know be known all over the
world he says if you don't give all
those ideas I think he called it
grandiosity if you don't give up all
these grandiose ideas of changing the
world
uh being rich being famous if you don't
change all those ideas
dude you'll never ever ever make it
you'll never stay what do you call it
you'll never stay dry and sober if
you're you're looking for uh if you have
money and you have health and you don't
have purpose and you don't have interest
and you don't have excitement and you're
not waking up every day but like like
with like hey I'm looking forward to
getting to the gym and working out if
you don't have those things going on or
I'm going to go on a vacation I'm going
to spend time with my grandkids or my
kids or I'm gonna write a book or
something exciting if you don't have
that you're going to burn okay so uh
first of all let me just say I don't
know everything I just know at 63 years
old I'm in the best shape of my life I'm
in the best financial condition of my
life and I'm the most excited I've ever
been in my entire life
that was not true just uh
16 year 16 years ago 17 years ago
is that right 63 12 years ago I'm sorry
12 years ago it wasn't that was not true
I was stressed I was burnt I had three
employees
two and a half employees
and only half of those worked
and I was doing all the work I was
running all over the country I was doing
250 days a year traveling picking up
checks I was a Salesman basically I was
a
[Music]
I would say uh
uh what's the word uh you know I was uh
was salesman was out selling pitching on
planes
doing about uh 100 000 miles a year on
American and United
uh buying a coach ticket
crossing my fingers hoping for an
upgrade stand at the Marriott on award
points you know the game right it was
away from my family had a new family at
the time I just got married I was
traveling every day my quality of my
life was terrible
and
I made a decision to get off
a challenge myself to get off the
treadmill of that treadmill now I knew
that I couldn't get off that treadmill
if I didn't have something else to go to
so I started studying people that have
scaled their finances
I needed money to work for me I didn't
need to keep working for the money I had
a little bit of money put away but I was
terrified of it if you know what I mean
by the way if you're running this
channel for the first time more and more
people are using the YouTube channels
and the Instagram people our age are
using it to access information I dropped
I've dropped about 5 000 videos in this
Channel about sales marketing starting
over scaling health
finances real estate I started playing
this real estate game hard about 12
years ago I started spending more time
investing in real estate than I did on
picking up a sales check
I started pulling away from some of the
old ideas that I had been sold as a kid
by the banks in Wall Street which was
Diversified retirement accounts 401ks
IRAs I took my IRA and my 401K money
that and it was self-directed and I
basically took control of it and took it
away from Fidelity and a Schwab and Wall
Street I took that money away from them
a couple things that I did I went and
looked at my money I had money in
savings accounts check-ins accounts
money markets where else I had some
mutual funds I had ETFs I had 401ks and
Ira all of it either sitting in money
markets or Garbage Paper Stock and I
pulled all control of that money back
over I also had equity in a home I
grabbed the equity at home I sold the
home
and went rented I literally re-worked
the entire finances in my life just keep
this in mind think about this you don't
have to go do it today and you don't
have to you don't have to be right or
wrong on this deal hey how do I grow my
business 10 times not one or two times
how could I scale my business out so
that I have maybe you have a hundred
customers or 200 customers how could I
have 2 000 customers you got 2 000 how
could I have 20 000 customers this is
what the big companies do you got four
employees that you don't like how could
I have 40 employees
and have somebody else handle
[Music]
the 40 that I don't like
[Music]
because what's happening right now is
people are scaling down when they should
be scaling up if you don't like your
financial condition look at your
environment
my my financial condition has been an
indication of the people around me and
when I'm listening to every day if you
don't have something I'm not talking
about a book right now I'm talking about
you guys need to be buried in content
buried immersed how many of you heard
this the same uh I'm drinking the
Kool-Aid
you need to swim in it
drown yourself in it you need to immerse
yourself inject it into your arm you
need to smell it breathe it love it
drink it immerse yourself in whatever
Kool-Aid you're going to drink be all in
No One's Gonna come to your house and
make your dreams come true it won't
happen it's not going to come through
the TV not going to come to you on
Facebook it's going to become because
you have a place to go every day
and get your head right your attitude
right how many believe you're an
attitude business first
oh wow
seven people
yeah I'm all in man I'm all in how many
you got people on your team like this
man yeah yeah man I'm gonna do good man
I'm gonna do good I'm I'm going after
how many of you heard people building
teams say I can't find good people
yeah what's the point
why are you telling that to other people
why do you tell that to other people why
are you trying to make sense of not
finding good people you get what you
think and say every day
I can't find any good people seven
billion people on planet Earth you can't
find good people because you quit
quit
so you just need to know the truth when
you criticize anything you're saying
something about yourself see I don't get
rid of haters I I'm like come on man
bring it on dog tell me about yourself
you talk about money too much you ain't
got any
you work too hard you don't work hard
enough
you too cocky you ain't cocky enough
why are you gonna blame my swag because
you ain't got any
you're an introvert you bought into it
right somebody said you're shy and you
bought into it somebody said you don't
need to have a business you don't need
all that you don't need a jet you don't
need the big house you don't need a
bunch of money do you gave up I didn't
give it to yourself you don't need to be
contagious
okay people quit this organization and
what do they do oh yeah right what do
they say never write this down never
ever take advice from a quitter if you
quit anything
man I quit going to the gym it just
didn't work for me I don't need to hear
that from you
I'm gonna get different information from
the people still going to the gym would
you agree look if you don't believe in
you enough to invest in yourself every
day I don't have time I got the kids I
got the wife I got the marriage I got
the problem I got the Boy Scouts I got
this dude you're sold on something else
I don't even know what you're talking
about right now
you're you're manufacturing excuses
to contaminate other people I don't need
to hear about all your problems I don't
care look if you're waking up today and
you're not feeling it I'm not talking
about workouts either whatever it is
going to work making a call
cleaning up something that you had to
clean up handling some problem that you
have and you're waking up feeling a
little depressed kind of down
uh
you know what I'm talking about just
don't quite fill it
expects me to be up all the time fixed
I'm supposed to
you know be Mr
10x misters 100 percent every day
it's never the case never so look if you
run into this channel for the first time
subscribe to it I'm going to share three
things that I do to get me through this
and make sure you comment or like
I'm building this channel out I spent
the last 10 years building out with
content material
he said I'm discovering in my life and
in my business
in hopes that it will help people
and
I don't have all the right answers I
just want you to know like
40 of the time I'm wrong maybe a little
more than that actually
I just got to be right on the big things
you know
one thing that
has helped me whether it was writing a
book and finishing it
or starting my speaking career when I
did it 30 years old I was going door to
door
to businesses around America flew three
million miles
go to City I was living in Houston at
the time
in Bel Air Texas and I'd fly to Salt
Lake City and I'd call on business
owners
I'd set a an event two weeks in advance
commit to the hotel fly to Salt Lake
City knew no one no one knew me I had no
name no books
there was no social media
and
had no clue what I was
when I was well I was calling on
don't even know how much I believed in
what I was doing like
I didn't believe in it
but it was like
you know I didn't have any statistics or
facts or success stories
and
regardless of how I felt just like this
morning regardless how much doubt there
was or uncertainty
uh
here
no matter who you're watching or who
you're following
whether it's
political person uh
a rapper movie star
teacher coach parents I don't care how
much in confidence they put out how much
athlete how much confidence or
certainty that they push out push out
like like project
they wake up there's days they wake up
and they don't feel it they don't feel
it they don't they don't want to do it
they're uncertain
they're feeling some low-grade
depression whatever you want to call it
look I woke up like that this morning
when got up family's not here this
weekend
uh Elena's got the kids she's teaching
them how to shoot guns this weekend
myself so I'm waking up this morning
like I don't want to work out I missed
yesterday
I'm not feeling it
what do you guys do when you don't feel
it
so this is what I do I just get a little
closer
this is what I do I get a little closer
just like I did when I was 30 years old
starting my speaking career never
thought I'd be one of the top considered
one of the top
two or three speakers in the world when
I was 30 years old I wanted that
but I didn't know how I was going to get
to that
and what I did was when I was having to
fly to these cities Salt Lake City
Winnipeg Saskatoon Toronto Vancouver
Chicago New York like I've never even
been into these places I was literally
flying to cities for the first time in
my entire career didn't know the
language didn't know the the culture
didn't know how they
little changes and that happened between
Toronto and New York New York and
Chicago Chicago and Dallas and Dallas
and Salt Lake Salt Lake and L.A those
are all very very different markets and
different people and different thinking
terrified
okay I'm doing this today to tell you I
was terrified I was so scared most the
time that it felt like not fear it felt
like depression like I wanted to take
the the sheets just pull them over my
head so what I did to conquer that to
handle that
literally would just get a little closer
and get myself a little closer to the
action like this morning I just got
close to the gym I actually went and
walked by the pool I have a pool in the
same spot that we have a gym on the
second floor here and I walked out there
and as I passed the gym
they're still doing the social
distancing [ __ ] here
um
there was nobody in here I'm like okay
there's nobody in here it's a sign I'm
gonna go in there and work out okay so
number one just try getting a little
closer to the action I hope that helps
you just get a little closer you don't
have to commit to doing it completely
just get closer to it I came down here
dressed
uh put that I put that on before I left
so I was ready so I got a little closer
second thing dude if it calls you
do it anyway
you know I coined this phrase years ago
do it anyway
buddy of mine about the same time I was
starting my business I was having a lot
of problems in my life I was probably
it was before I started my business I
was still in Houston Texas I was going
through tremendous tremendous amounts of
uncertainty doubt about myself I was in
a transition a career transition just
lost a job
starting my deal and
I went one year one year without working
I've never ever shared this before one
year and I did not I mean I had a little
bit of money saved and I was going
through it I didn't I didn't literally I
looked like I was working every day but
in truth I was not working my twin
brother actually knew that and finally
confronted me and that's what got me off
my ass but
this guy told me he's like look you wake
up in the morning and no matter what
you're feeling
no matter how much you hurt
your eyes are bleeding
do it anyway this financial statement on
this page is for companies
individuals and households
every company a country a city every
company individuals you want to make a
note here companies individuals and
households
okay if you're a household a bill Bill's
a household he's got a household I know
he's got a household he's got to have a
house I don't know who's in the house
his household has a budget he's got
income coming in expenses going out
that's a financial statement that's what
that is right there income uh uh less
expenses equals what's left over period
end of story that could be Google
Facebook your house it could be a
company it could be a country it could
be a city they're all the same by the
way I go to Canada Japan I go to
Singapore Dubai Detroit and the
financial statement will be identical
the language will change the financial
statements will be identical everywhere
you go the top line of every financial
statement for a household or a company
or a city is what
Revenue income or sales okay this used
to be sales and then some accounted how
many accountants in the room
smart person okay said oh we need to
change that to like to like Revenue
it used to be simple sales
okay and then somebody's like oh we got
to call that something better
okay we're gonna call it Revenue it
sounds more professional
dude it's sales okay how many of you
don't like sales
how many of you in a room let me see
your hand if you don't like sales okay
if you're no good at it you don't
like so that means everybody in the
room's a damn Masters sensei
[Music]
on the uh on the uh on the up here uh
doing the sales thing Dave Todd how good
are those guys
are they good
and I show up around 11 o'clock and I
show you a different variation you're
like dang doc another level
that don't make you a sensei
right so like like I've done my thing
I've done my thing 30 years
there's a big difference between 30
years and six years
like I know every little crevice and I'm
still learning I know little little
angles like one thing means a thousand
things to me not ten you understand
because I played the game a little
longer so you get deeper you get sensei
so there's a lot of levels to the game
man sales is about Revenue folks if you
don't like sales you want to write this
down if you don't like sales
you don't like Revenue
so get a t-shirt
I hate Revenue
I hate sales scratch it out but I hate
Revenue
[Music]
[Applause]
because if you don't like sales you're
in trouble at home you're in trouble for
your city you're in trouble for your
community you're in trouble everywhere
if you don't like income because you
unlike the government can't print money
it's against the law that's why the
America the United States government the
only product the United States
government has
is the printing of money there is no
other product
they print money so you work
you work you'll never create wealth okay
you want to write this down well no
matter how hard you work
Okay
Kevin can work his ass off
he can work 20 hours a day
he will never create wealth work he will
only create wealth when he invests I'm
about to move I'm moving from Los
Angeles California where I've been 22
years in California my wife's been here
23 years she came here to be an actress
at 17 years old and we're picking up and
we're moving everything I wrote the
governor a letter three months ago and
said dude you keep raising my taxes I'm
out of here by the way you should be
doing that you should be thinking about
hey how can I avoid 7 8 9 10 or 11 state
income taxes most of you don't even know
what your income tax is you think when
you buy something sales tax is your
income tax I'm talking about the income
tax you pay on earned income that you
earned Jerry Brown didn't earn any of it
so I tell Jerry Brown I'm done dude if
you keep raising my taxes they're going
in that direction we're like okay we're
out of here now I got to tell you man it
is scary moving it is terrifying to move
I'm like I'ma move to Miami I'm gonna go
live in a new place we're going to rent
a house for a while we're going to
figure out we got to make new friends we
don't know anybody there all that stuff
right
all the trouble figuring out the
calendar the money it costs to move all
that and then I'm like wait a minute
what are you worried about dude
you so pinned down to one place you
can't get up and move every once in a
while
it reminds me of how many people don't
want change the way it was is in the
past the way it's gonna be is in the
future so what is it going to mean a lot
of trouble me and my wife the kids new
furniture new house new place new
friends I gotta talk these guys here at
the company hey guys a year from now
maybe two years from now we're going to
shut this thing down in LA and you guys
are going to move over there with me but
look change is good don't be scared of
it you're not pinned down like like you
were like as 400 years ago and you lived
in some village where they convinced you
that the world was flat remember that I
think that's why we get scared of moving
the World is Flat don't leave the
village you'll fall off
no you won't you're just going to change
you're going to evolve you're going to
make new friends dude if you need to
pick up and go some other place to make
your life better your family better to
find Great Schools to make more money
pick your [ __ ] up and move my dad worked
his ass off and when he died
he did good my mom had to sell
everything
and so I'm like okay that didn't work
but he was considered successful the
middle class successful briefcase good
job professional people respected him
saved his money had life insurance house
was paid for everything by the book
and she was unloading stuff the next
week because she was terrified and so
from the age of 10 to like 16 17 years
old we were just scared dude clipping
coupons
buying everything on sale
single mother everywhere she goes she
knows they're going to rip her off the
plumber the roofer the car dealer
everybody's gonna rip her off save your
money save for a rainy day yeah you know
a penny saved is
it's not it's a penny yeah right it's a
penny yeah I mean it's a penny dude you
want to pick a penny up today you ain't
with a penny the third thing I would say
about wealthy people is they're
I mean different people have different
ways they invest but they tend to be
more focused on the long-term
appreciation of an asset
rather than give me money this second
and and I think to get they're they're
not stuck in this get rich quick thing
it's a delayed gratification yeah
they're more like yeah I'd rather have
wealth tomorrow than Rich today
and they do have a distinction between
the rich and the wealthy the you know
the super wealthy are looking to create
wealth beyond their own means and needs
like they're not thinking about their
kids their boat their plane I know
people think that but that's not
actually true they're actually thinking
about how do I create wealth for a a lot
of people Amazon's got a million
employees
yeah now most of them only earn minimum
wage but there's some people at the
upper level of Amazon that are making
fortunes success is vital absolutely
maybe you've heard me say this before
it's worth writing down again success is
your duty it is your obligation and your
responsibility success to me is as vital
to my survival as oxygen food and water
shelter I gotta have shelter I gotta
have water I have to have oxygen I need
food okay I need love in my life okay I
need people I need human interaction and
I also need to win if you don't have
success in your life you will lose
discipline you will lose activity you
will lose contacts and you will not be
consistent you will not have them this
is the vital part of success this is why
I'm pounding to you the only trick in
this universe if there is a trick at all
is you must be successful success is not
an option it is your duty it is your
obligation it is your responsibility
2022 if it's going to be good for you
and your family
if it's going to be great for you and
your family it is because you demand
success this year and that means you
demand success in your relationships in
your finances and in your money I
disregard my feelings like like my
feelings you know feelings are overrated
in our society like he
yeah
they're they're gonna mislead you
they're not I gotta follow my gut no no
I don't even know what you're talking
about you most people don't know where
their gut is their gut your gut is a
it's a stomach it's called a stomach
okay it's not designed to lead you it's
designed to digest food so so I I don't
I follow the data right and and my
emotions my emotions fear would keep me
from doing fears kept me from doing I
should be I should be a billionaire
eight or nine times right now what is
that stuff fear kept me from doing these
the deals I'm doing today fear kept me
from doing 20 years ago so what were you
actually afraid of I I was afraid I
lacked confidence in in the data I
didn't I didn't trust the data I knew I
have known for years this little space
that I'm in
um I mean in so many different places
but particularly in the real estate I've
known for years that there was going to
be a massive shift in America
particularly and maybe around the world
to where people will no longer buy homes
and they will live they will they will
lease where they live and they will move
around the country their Mobility will
become a big thing and I knew that I
knew that but I did I should have put
every penny I should have borrowed more
money I should I should own 40 000 units
down not uh seven thousand so maybe
maybe 70 I could be one of the biggest
landowners in America today had I
followed my imp my my data my instincts
that was backed by data rather than my
feelings and listening to the numbnuts
around me that are like don't do it
don't take the risk you don't need to
you already have enough all you're going
to do is like all that input from other
people you know we I bought a I bought a
plane uh maybe three or four years ago
and I've taken a bunch of heat about the
plane because people are like oh he's
showing up his plane look if you had a
guy if you had a jet you would show it
off too and if you didn't show it to
people
uh shame on you like it's inspiration
for most people not envy for most people
they're like dude that inspires me Mark
Wright was here yesterday he was on you
know Mark I
so he flew with me from Cardiff to
London last year I put him on the plane
he says Grant you ruined my whole life
put me on that plane I can't think like
every time I get on a plane and I'm like
oh my God I need that flat private it it
is a like it is a Ruiner and this is
what like if I inspire people to think
bigger that that is one of my goals
because that has been the big ruin of my
life that I didn't think big enough the
whole time the big single biggest regret
I have in my life I played a small
for
at least 35 years
influenced by Society education friends
even friends with good intentions family
members that love me you know they're
the wrong people
to let the the you know the foul country
I did yesterday the the one of these
birds the Peregrine pair of pair of
something moves at 200 miles an hour
makes an aerial strike kills on contact
like it's like wow man it only had it
only it only does three things in his
life it either kills you gets killed by
you or has sex with you you guys have to
learn this Finance game it's a different
game than your moms and dad uncles and
aunts and your gramps played okay they
were trying to pay everything off they
were trying to earn money you really in
in today's society you don't really want
to earn money you have to do that in the
beginning but what you want to do is you
want to get money or equity you really
want money to become equity and you want
the equity to go up Elon Musk posted or
tweeted Sunday
he's like I know there's a lot of talk
about the capital gains tax
he said but you guys need to understand
and there's a lot of talk about
billionaires paying taxes he's like you
guys need to understand I don't earn
income
I can I only pay taxes when I sell
shares of my Tesla
and and and so like people need to
understand that's the game you know my
dad wanted to earn more money my dad
wanted to get into the middle class my
dad wanted a better job my dad wanted to
have more money so he could buy a house
so he could pay it off he could he could
buy life insurance for the family he
could pay that off he could uh have
money left over for a savings account or
a money market or you know stuff right
but but you see that's not the game guys
the game is to study the top the top
wealthiest people in the world and what
they're doing is they're they're Jay-Z
talks about Equity he's like yeah you're
going you're going for the advance I'm
going for the equity
you know and and when you're on the up
when you're trying to get up you're
trying to get that Advance you want the
bag so bad that we never learn how to
keep it and then we never learn how to
multiply I'm out I have one income in
the beginning and and what do I need
what do I need in addition to one income
I need a second income that I ideally
don't have to work for okay I don't want
the second income to take attention from
the first income
this is where people make a big mistake
they go out and get one income they bust
in their ass to get one income and then
they go invest in a second thing start a
second company and the second company
makes the first income happy income
because they don't pay attention to it
anymore I wanted my first income to grow
my second income to take zero attention
from me so what I did was I took money
from the first threw it in real estate
like I'm showing you in the back here
that's playing on my TV right now this
is a deal we're doing right now put the
money in the real estate I don't lose my
money I know it's not going to go down
in value
it's supported by cash flow and three I
just wait for the growth of rent
so all we buy is and and this is why I
would say no to people on bitcoin right
now and ethereum any of the coins number
one you could lose your money
if if if you're just getting started you
don't lose money man number two you're
not getting income none of the coins pay
income crypto does not pay income and if
you're 25 35 years old you need income
not just a score
now all that being said
how does how does my real estate compare
to crypto or Amazon
well I can tell you that that piece of
real estate that I'm showing you right
there I'm gonna pay 230 million dollars
for that I'm gonna sell it for a half a
billion dollars
and I'm gonna be paid to wait for a for
a hundred percent return on the total
price
but because it's the real estate
I only I don't pay the whole price I'll
pay you about 70 million for that
property
70 million will become
500 million
uh which is about a six x return with no
threat of loss
income while I wait and great tax
advantages I always thought that I could
do something I I think everybody
thinks I think everyone does that yeah I
think everybody does I think every
person thinks that they're special
but do you think if they would if they
would be really honest and not not I
think that they have the thought and
then and then they're like I can't tell
anybody that because that white people
judge them well they will judge them
they will judge them like your parents
will tell you you're special until you
start acting like you're special and
then they want to medicate you so like
oh you're so special you know he's so
special right and then and then then
special becomes a problem somewhere
between I don't know eight years old and
15. special takes on a different meaning
than it than if you're 24 months old and
then and there becomes a problem for the
adults right so I think everyone is
special I think if everybody got really
quiet
and anything you could say anything they
everybody would be like yeah dude I got
this special little thing I got the
superpower I got this you know this
thing and then what happens is it gets
squelched for me I squelched it so hard
I suppressed it and pushed it down so
hard because because I was told to like
it was not
the the
my surroundings did not like me
exhibiting
my my special right so so you know
because because I was awkward it was
special like in the beginning you don't
know how to use it so for me I've always
been very uh rough uh I was in Dubai and
this lady says oh my God I loved meeting
this guy she was I saw her write an
article about me I love meeting this guy
he's a bit rough
but but and I've always been that I've
always been a very kind of the edges are
Jagged Jenny has a reason for that
because I'm trying to figure it out I'm
trying to figure it out it's and still
be me without without suppressing who I
am right so I'm trying to I'm I'm a bit
I'm very playful uh I'm immature
I I love pranks I like having fun more
than I like anything like I want to have
fun but I want the fun but but then I
then I become very serious when it's
time to work so I go from this
very playful person to this extremely
intense
it can happen in a in a micro of a
second yeah that we could be you know
screwing around doing something dumb too
okay now we're in a deal and if your
phone's on and like I'm in the deal now
do you know that adaptability has helped
you get to what you are yeah I think
it's helped me and hurt me though
because because it's very confusing for
people even people very close to me I
get it yeah so I remember it reminds me
of a time when Elena and I my wife
she went she bought something I forget
what it was I said how much was that and
she's like I don't know I said find out
how much it was you got to know what
things cost because that bothered me
like I don't know and then she told me
I'm like Helena that was ridiculous we
didn't need it instead I could have got
a better deal blah blah blah it was no
money I didn't it was 500 bucks or
something
literally three minutes later I was
negotiating a deal and bought it for 62
million dollars or something instead of
ridiculous
so I went from being micromanaging
probably incorrectly over 500 bucks to
spend at 60 60 million dollars and she
and she it was confusing for us
confusing for the people around you
you know when you're making decisions
like on your whiteboard saying you know
what I'm going to throw away my main
business I'm gonna go away I'm gonna go
for this other business it it scares
people when you start changing people
don't get wealthy diversifying they
don't accumulate wealth they may
preserve it by they preserve it later
later they might do it uh by the way
Warren Buffett would if Warren Buffett
could own all the Coca-Cola or AIG which
is what he started with he would he
can't
uh he he has of all his Investments four
of his Investments four represents 75 of
his entire portfolio Mark Cuban said
that uh diversifications for idiots uh
Elon Musk has three investments in his
portfolio all of which he wants Steve
Jobs had two Investments Pixar and apple
it is not true only the financial
planner only the financial planner who
might not even be a millionaire would
suggest that you diversify or or Wall
Street or the banks a banker will tell
you to diversify but there's no Bankers
got four billion dollars worth of assets
so I got four billion dollars worth of
this real estate right here
and and
you know
I have two million dollars worth of uh
Bitcoin
so I only have the Bitcoin because
somebody gave it to me
that's a big gift Grand yeah yeah well
they yeah yeah so so I and I added a
little bit once I understood it but or
partially understood it but this stuff
right here look I know
I know that monk cash is garbage
Euros pounds
pesos whatever you want to call it
Spanish dollars it's all garbage it's
completely made up
um you know I I like the argument for
crypto I don't like the fact that when
you're on the come up and you're 35
years old what you need more than
anything is income
you need a flow of income that you can
depend on so that if you're not working
or can't work or something happens you
still have income to pay for your rent
or pay for your food because you still
got to eat and most people I haven't
seen anybody going to the food to the to
the store and trading their crypto for
some Whole Foods you mean there's no
yield in crypto there's no usual exactly
there's no cash flow and now
if you're a gambler
dude and you want to put it all oh I
would never put it all in why wouldn't
you see this is the question I ask
people dude if you know for sure cryptos
a play if you know it's going to the
moon the Dogecoin
if you know for sure it's going to go to
a hundred thousand then put everything
in it you see I'm not that sure
so because I'm not that sure I can't
make that big bet
and the way to create real wealth is to
make massive bets if particularly
particularly with your story about hey I
don't want to wait till I'm 90 years old
and Warren by the way Warren started
when he was 50. he didn't make any real
money until he's 50 years old but I
would just tell people look if you want
to make massive money then you need to
put you need to go all in first on you
second on your business not on real
estate or crypto the best return in the
world is your business the best return
in the world is an idea I got an idea
I'm gonna write a book I go out and sell
a million copies of a book there's no
better return than that
because it came from nothing right it
came from the mud
um now once you got money coming in from
the book sales how do you protect the
money okay well you you go all in on one
stock uh you could go by Amazon today
for thirty thirty five hundred dollars
but I'll tell you this piece of real
estate right here will make more money
for me and my family than Amazon will
ever make
because what will happen with this real
estate that you can't do with Amazon and
you can't do with Bitcoin I'm going to
wait 10 years on this piece of Real
Estate
I'm going to take all my Capital out of
the deal I'm going to refinance it still
own the asset and get my down payment
back so I'll get my 70 million dollars
back or 7 million whatever the number is
this is a big big deal so it's 230
million dollars I could take it down to
20 million or I could take it down to
two it's the same math all the way
across the board it's just different
zeros yeah
go for it go for it no but but this
asset class this particular asset class
allows the everyday person
to create wealth in a way that Wall
Street has been doing for years which is
I buy an asset it goes up in value
because because the income goes up
without my effort and then when it goes
up in value I refinance it grab my
initial monies out of it now I have that
money back it's a non-taxable event
worldwide by the way worldwide that
becomes a non-taxable event
I refinanced the property it continues
to cash flow and pay me money but I have
no money in it this is the true wealth
formula uh which where we're using
leverage against an increased assets
value going forward I am not going to
invest with you if you don't know what
you're talking about where is it I don't
know what's the job growth I don't know
what's the rent I don't know what's the
next door I don't know what's the NOS I
don't know okay nobody like next who's
serious number three not knowing your
underwriting you got to know your
underwriting
it's better for you when we meet
Wednesday night it's better that you
don't know you're underwriting with me
than when you do it with the bank
you do not want to mess up with the bank
they're not going to forgive you once
one time they're gonna be like leave
this guy alone they'll never forgive you
for it you will never they will never
you'll never get in their good graces
if you mess up with them on top because
they're cowards that's not their money
they're Lending
uh number four
you got to buy through every cycle
you cannot wait for the bust out you got
to buy it through the good times you got
to buy through the bad times you got to
buy all the time
so before covet I was buying during
covet I was buying after covet I was
buying so when I'm on a phone call with
somebody I was on a phone call today I
said guys they said what'd you buy
during covet 600 million dollars worth
of stuff they're like dang man
like that shows tremendous confidence
that I can go do a deal through
uncertain times
number five buying too small buying too
small is a problem it's a headache it's
a pain in the ass okay six being talked
out of deals
leave the people around you alone get
somebody this Pro on this thing don't
talk to your stock broker or your
financial planner do not talk to your
dentist or your chiropractor about
buying real estate
let them
crack your back and then get off the
table and go back to buying some real
estate uh number seven not looking at
enough deals these are the mistakes
you're going to make you're not going to
look at enough deals you're going to
look at a couple and quit keep looking
at deals they're going to stack the
information is going to stack I remember
one of my jobs was I was in a produce
department in Lake Charles Louisiana in
a grocery store and I was I was telling
Jared about produce the other day I was
I hated this job
the guys tell me look man when the
bananas get some bruises on it
you got to move them to the front
didn't know I was learning something
fast forward 50 years
when when an event's getting close to
being expiring move that event to the
front
you understand as you're losing time
because your product's going to get
bruised and expire move it to the front
like I didn't know when I was 16 years
old that I was learning when I was
stacking the shelves and they taught me
how to stack the Cheerios
and the brillo pads
and the tide and they told me how to
pull it to the front keep it squared up
I didn't know I was learning to pack
and control my environment when you look
at a lot of deals this deal is going to
teach you about that deal is going to
teach you about that deal it's going to
teach you about that deal and then one
day you're going to be like this deal
right here is sick because of these
deals and you're gonna know for sure
because you knew those you because these
gave you the data you needed to buy that
one okay one deal can what
number eight I need to write a book one
deal could change your life so I want to
give you a list of things to drop
your drama
reduce your risk how many of you'd like
to never lose money on a deal check off
most of this list and you won't lose
money on a deal number one is the
location good
the better the location gets the better
off you are should have asked Robert
that would you rather pay a higher price
for a better location or a lower price
for a worse location I think I know what
he would tell me is it affordable
affordable to who
to the tenant based on what else I can
buy in that area Okay New York City
rents should be higher than uh than a
Miami rents
okay if if I'm in if I'm at Fifth Avenue
right in the every condo is 12 million
dollars
and I can rent there for 5500 bucks a
month for a little tiny apartment or if
I go to Silicon Valley and people are
being paid 250 250 000 to work at
Facebook as an intern
I can pay nine thousand dollar a month
in rent and those rents by the way you
have 1970
1970 built product it was built in 1970
Elena were you were you born in 1970
she wasn't even born yet and there's
apartments that were built in 1970 50
plus 52 years old
that rent for nine thousand dollars a
month one bedroom 800 square feet old
ass kitchen bad floors bad cabinets
leaky faucets that rent for nine grand a
month
and somebody bought those years ago a
guarantee they probably only paid 9 000
for the unit and every month they
collect another nine grand if they've
been there long enough okay is it so it
could be affordable right even though
it's nine thousand you take the rents in
Miami at 1500 2800 anywhere in between
15 and 2800.
same asset you take that and transport
it to New York City those rents are 25
000 bucks a month
take the same property push it to
Singapore
Singapore rents are 80 percent higher in
the United States of America you guys
complain about the rents you guys
complain about the rents because the
locals never change the market you want
to write this down the locals never
changed the market The Outsiders did why
are Apartments Superior this is what I
want you guys to hear my flipper my
flipper friend in Austin the gentleman
with the Cardone Capital Hat number one
housing is a basic need number two
apartments are an economic Preferred
Choice number three apartments are the
preferred choice of housing today people
want to rent as an option they want the
mobility and the freedom to do so okay
number four it cannot be easily replaced
these 300 unit complexes that you're
seeing being built in the rallies and
the Carolinas all across the Eastern
Seaboard once it's there they're going
to build another one across the street
sooner or later it's all gone Houston
Texas this year consumed 50 percent of
all their inventory their apartment
inventory in the first five months of
the year this is called absorption
absorption is how fast new units are
being consumed okay or purchased they
can't be easy to replace what happens if
inflation happens to glass metal Lumber
we've had like crazy Lumber inflation
what about I can't get Workers to build
a 300 unit complex the housing
manufacturers they're not building
houses anymore they're building
apartment complexes number five it has
the potential to produce and provide
cash flow for the investors number six
bankable asset very very easy to get
debt on way easier than most every other
asset class number seven it's got a
multiplier effect two things on the
multiplier effect if you're taking notes
one rinse can go up okay and The
Leverage from the property
this is the multiplier effect so if
these rents go up 200 bucks or 300 or 3
000 whatever number you want the rents
go up times 12 times 10 if you're going
to hold for 10 years and what if they
keep bouncing is there any chance the
rents are going to go up the first
property I bought was in San Diego
California 1998 okay we were moving the
rents two and three hundred dollars
every month leverage leverage able
assets
okay you want to make a note here to
create wealth you want to buy assets
that appreciate and value enough
refinance those assets at new higher
valuation pull out all their Equity to
create a non-taxable event meaning I
could get 50 million dollars and not pay
taxes and still own assets so if I could
just play this game one build at a time
I get a building wait three or four
years increase the rents get my money
out keep the building next go add
another Builder with the money that I
got from the first building you with me
and I just keep moving up
pretty well for yourself you cannot
create wealth without investing doesn't
matter how hard you work nine number
nine you have multiple exits on this
stuff I could sell it I could refinance
it that's called an exit no exit grab my
money but I don't exit the property okay
number 10 historic doubles every decade
Apartments double every 10 years in my
employer every 10 years to a million
dollar deal doubles two million it
succeeded any of our expectations it's
just beautiful I mean I would pick
helping people over everything over
everything so so only because my heart
kind of pulls me to help people because
I wanted help when I was a kid and
um I didn't have anybody to help me and
it was frustrating and I just I I have
this personal promise that I made years
ago that if I ever made it I would
um I would stay revealed and I would
help people I would show them what I'm
doing so
um and that thing pulls at me it
probably cost me you know a lot of time
and energy because but but it pulls me
it's kind of like a mission to Steve
Harvey told me once he's like you know
Steve Harvey he's got this beautiful
saying about he his career is what pays
his bills but his
mission is what pays his heart or
something like that he says it much
better than I did catchy people can't
see everything you know I've I've
learned this in my own life and with
other people like people that take
shortcuts can't see very well
and and like you you already you can see
everything I'm doing you see the
e-commerce you see the traditional you
see the the sales calls that we make you
see what I'm doing on social you see the
real estate place you see everything I'm
doing
so another person could study everything
that I'm doing and not see everything
I'm doing because
they're sketchy and they're like stuck
right here they're criminals they're
they're they're they're they're they're
they're taking shortcuts and they're
they're looking for short cuts and all
they see is shortcuts they don't they
can't see everything so the more honest
the person is the more they can see and
the less honest a person is the less
they can see it's it's why a thief a
thief you know Robs a house and steals
less than he could have made just
servicing the same exact house
right the guy would have given more
money to like take care of him if he
could see instead he saw a watch and
took the watch I say this all the time
like if you love
if you learn to love the thing you hate
you might find a big gift in it and for
me I didn't like sales I hated it I
tried sellings when I was 17 years old
lost a job 18 I tried again part-time
during the summer lost the job 19 years
old lost the job I had had five
experiences in sales and hated every one
of them all different Industries I just
kept moving Industries thinking okay
it'll be different this will be easy to
sell I hated sales I hated talking to
people I particularly hated the
beginning the Rapport building you know
I'm not good at breaking ice like Ron
Seco he can talk to anybody I can't do
that I can't go into a room
um I could speak to 35 000 people but I
can't go into a room and start warming
it up
uh it's just I'm uncomfortable so
the point I'm trying to make is when I
was 25 the only job I could get was a
sales job and I said hey you got to
decide that you're going to get good at
this even if you hate it yeah because
you can't lose another job it would have
been my sixth firing and I'm like I
cannot lose another job I did by the way
get fired from that place but they never
got rid of me because I kept selling
stuff so every time they fire me I'd go
back and sell something they'd be like
okay stay another day until until the
next time you mess up something so
you know I went from hating sales to
committing to it to becoming now known
as like one of the greatest living sales
people on the planet so in the things
you hate yeah yeah like where does the
hate come from like the things that you
hate
the things that just grind you out like
you're just bug you there's probably if
you just stay with it and look just move
to the side a little bit and look behind
it there might be some great gifts so
spiritual audience the number one one
most important thing to me in my life
like before my wife and my kids is my
understanding of God yeah and and my
dreams come from that connection and
that understanding and my my dreams and
my goals are not really Financial it's
potential
so so so when I talk about
you know people ask me
the probably the most painful question I
get is when is enough enough
and I'm like man you guys are to check
in with God on that
yeah right because because my my
potential
is what I'm going after it's not it's
not some number I got a guy asking me
about my net worth I'm like dude what
it's a stupid question
it's the ego it's an ego it's an ego
thing right what I'm interested in is my
potential possibility discovery
and and and for me that potential is the
thing that strings me and God
and that potential is my dreams it's
like what what could I do what's
possible
and the the other thing is about the
blessing you know you you hear people I
was in Atlanta I'm like man I'm blessed
and everybody's like oh yeah praise the
Lord I'm like yeah everybody's blessed
everybody's blessed I've never met
somebody that's not blessed
most people are not proven it though
they're blessed and not validating God
every day wow so uh I have a very very
powerful very strong and very clear
understanding of my relationship with
God and it is first and foremost with me
other people want to understand it right
but but but I every every day every day
every deal undoing a deal
like I've undone deals hey guys this
deal is no longer good for me
and that was me and my my highest
ethical
what do you mean you got a deal we got a
deal you signed a contract that's right
and now we're going to undo this deal
and I'm gonna undo it we're going to
talk about it we're going to figure it
out
hey hey this deal is not good for me and
if it's not good for me it's not good
for my family it's not good for my
future it's not good for my my ability
to give to Charities it's not good for
you either
so rather than me just walking away why
don't we just rework the deal so that
we're both happy and everybody went very
difficult thing to do
yeah because another person because
another person might be bound by that
agreement they're like no no we have a
deal I have to do what I said I'm going
to do because they're Bound by some rule
that they made some agreement hey if
that agreement's no longer good for you
no God would want you to continue what
you'd want to do is communicate which is
harder to do yeah you know so so
the ability for my wife and I to
communicate about anything even if it's
tough and it's you know it's
you know how have it believing in God is
more than just believing in God it takes
courage
to to go out every day and validate it
because if you actually believe you have
to deal and you ought to do well too and
if you have a you know to me in my mind
like
you know if I have if I have a good
really strong good working relationship
with God I would be successful at
everything
physically in my marriage in business
with my customers online
I would have good reviews not bad
reviews yeah like you already have the
whole package I don't think
I know I don't think God had a partial
package I think it was probably the
whole deal
and the other thing is the work thing
you know like
I see a lot of people that believe in
God that don't work
you know they're like oh yeah but you
know
they're taking two and three days off
God don't even take that much time off
he takes one day off yeah look what he
did before he took the day off we got to
look at your vehicle what vehicle are
you in right now
you have any recurring Revenue
do you have any opportunities outside of
what's going on right now
what are your assets and liabilities
take advantage of it if you're over 50
years old you're just trying to figure
out man what am I going to do because
look time is critical now you don't have
a lot of time you know you know that
better than I did
you got to figure this game out okay if
you're committed number one number two
got to look at the vehicle you're in
we've got to look at do you have any
other additional income or recurring
income or repetitive income passive
income opportunities there's so many
that exist in the world today if you
don't understand YouTube LinkedIn
Instagram all these things like I didn't
understand any of this when I was 51
years old I had no idea how to Market
myself I'd never branded myself I'd
never done video like this before I
didn't know if I did a video what I was
supposed to do the video on I did not
have a product lineup I was in one tiny
uh vertical I'd heard somebody say once
the riches are in the niches and my
Niche was so tight
I wasn't right I was wrong because I was
dependent upon this many people I had to
serve them satisfy them kneel down to
them and kiss the ring every day and I
got tired if you're tired of kneeling
down kissing the ring begging putting up
with bullets from customers you're 50
years old you're over 50 years old and
you're like okay I got to get recurring
Revenue
I got to get something that's
indestructible I got to figure out how
to do this without spending a bunch of
money I can't disrupt my main flow right
now you got a job right now you can't
walk away from it I get it
you're running out of time okay you got
what 10 years 15 years 20 years you want
to start enjoying it some of the money
some of the production 80 maybe 90 maybe
95 without being a doomsdayer
95 of the people in the United States of
America wealthiest country on the planet
are suffering no money no Freedom no
choices can't leave their job
tied down
and they most of those 95 percent most
of them some of them are earned in big
way just 250 Grand 80 grand 90 grand
maybe you're in this group 60 Grand 58
000 78 000 112 000 whatever number
you're earning if you look at the the
the money left over at the end of the
year end of the month or into the the
week
there's not a lot of money left over 76
percent of Americans are living paycheck
to paycheck 55 of Americans have no
money in a savings account okay 90 of
all the wealth in this country is owned
by about less than 10 percent of all the
people in this country listen to what I
just said
you and I have been doing something
wrong
we are using information that is
outdated and no longer efficient for the
kind of economy we're in today got all
kind of disruption going on you've got
to start thinking different about saving
money investing money real estate crypto
and how you how you uh do do you go over
many many Investments or do you go hard
on one we need to look at what you have
been taught about money that may be
holding you back that may not be the
thing you need to be doing any longer
I'm here in Las Vegas right now you know
when you walk in these casinos
almost everybody knows how to play
Blackjack
almost everybody knows how to play the
little games here they even have books
how to play the gangs the guy gets a six
he's got a 16 and the Dealer's got a six
he's like I'm not going to hit that card
and he's sits there and he gets beat all
night because he's playing by the book I
figured out two things
I figured out oh
excuse the language I've been doing
everything wrong and thought it was
right I was doing exactly what the book
said save your money invest in mutual
funds plan for retirement buy some life
insurance what was the other one work
hard
oh yeah you got to work hard and you do
by the way
that's not a myth but I know a lot of
people that are working on it that end
up with nothing
like my parents my dad worked hard he
died at 52 years old heart blew up in
his chest from stress and overwork
[Music]
probably for not taking care of himself
enough because he was out there grinding
just pounding pounding every day because
he wanted to do one thing to take care
of his family
probably same thing you want to do then
my mom was left to raise five kids
and only had a little bucket of money
sitting over there in a savings account
so she's clipping coupons terrified to
spend anything scared of the if the
plumbing breaks scared if the roofer
comes over scared terrified every day to
spend one penny because she knew she was
depleting the account that would take
care of the family
look if you're experiencing any of these
same things today don't feel bad about
yourself like you're not you're not like
oh what's wrong with me
what's wrong with you is you have the
wrong information
you got the wrong information it's not
because you're lazy it's not because
you're stupid it's because you have the
wrong data one of the things that
to me is the most difficult thing in my
entire career is becoming a top producer
because the moment you become a top
producer you become susceptible
thinking you have the life
I grew up in a little town in Louisiana
a little small town about 60 000 people
you probably hear the accent
and uh I grew up in a middle class a
middle class family my my dad died when
I was 10 years old my mother raised us
and my mother constantly told me how
proud I should be of myself
how many of you got a mother like that
you should be so proud of yourself okay
every time my mom was my best friend and
every time I would have a success it
didn't matter whether I was 18 years old
or 48 years old anytime I had a success
she was the first person I called I
wouldn't call my girlfriend wouldn't
call my wife wouldn't call any of the
people that were closest to me I called
my mom said mom you never believe I just
bought a real estate deal I started this
company I bought my first real estate
deals 38 units it's four million dollars
and she'd be like that's awesome I love
you Just the Way You Are
and I'm like okay okay thanks she told
me that a thousand times how many had a
parent tell you I love you that's great
that's great you made 160 Grand last
year
but I love you just the way you are let
me hear that okay that's right out of
the 10x rule I don't know if you know
that that's right out of the four
actions
anybody know what action it is
average average I'm doing well okay
there's four levels of action number one
is I do nothing
if I rewrote this book I would take that
out that's actually impossible to do
nothing at all is impossible try doing
it right now foreign
to do nothing means you had to make a
decision to do something and not do it
this is actually not true I wouldn't put
it in the book If I rewrote it the
second level of action is
um to retreat this is what most people
do by the way
how many had a commitment to work out
today
and didn't
okay okay
I was up late whatever you came up with
whatever reason I'm gonna make the call
by the way any retreat in life any
single Retreat is a discipline and a
commitment to retreat when it matters
so so every time you make a decision you
just need to be aware that what are you
doing here okay there's only four things
you can do in any given day right you
could do nothing you could Retreat or
you could do this average
now I know you guys are being told that
you're the top
you're the top you're the best you made
it to Miami but I'm just going to tell
you right now ain't not a person in this
room is above number three
no I'm not there
okay and I know how much I'm grinding
every day how much I'm pushing every day
how many how many hours I put into a day
what's the maximum number of hours you
can do in a day
not if you add people
if you added people you got to think
beyond the 24th Thing Once you guys get
committed once you get committed then
you will come up with Solutions outside
the physical universe
okay you're already doing that your
space is your space is bizarre okay here
there's a bunch of people in the room
that
that like I don't know anything about
technology
I'm 61 years old I was born in 1958. I
am supposed to
posted side
of Technology yet I'm probably one of
the top five social media people in the
world today
banging on Instagram and Snapchat and
Linkedin and Google Plus that'll go away
using all these mechanisms to try to get
attention so that I can operate
at this level 10x thing this massive
level that is always changing by the way
you can't 10x something people are like
man I'd write the book If I wrote the
book I'd write it 11x I'm like that's
because you don't understand 10x dude
10x is a multiplier
it's 10x which is a hundred
okay so what what I do what I did in it
when Lehman collapsed I wrote the 10x
Rule and I wrote the book because I
realized I had done something wrong that
book was written for me and the reason
when I closed the book The reason I was
like ah whatever I had figured out what
I had done wrong okay I had to embrace
the the the idea that three or four
million dollars in a bank and a house
paid for and two cars and a marriage and
I got it better than everybody else and
my mama loves me just the way I am
was all this this middle class
this American particularly here in
America how many of you live in America
okay in America the middle class it is
the sleeping chamber
on planet Earth
okay people come here people come here
they come from India and China come to
here to get a middle class dude I don't
want anything to do with this
okay your middle class you will not
change the world
you might change your house you might
change the education your little kids
get okay they get to go to Texas A M big
deal right he told me that he went to
Texas I said oh that had to screw you up
back just going to college
well because what are they manufacturing
College
they manufacture average people at
college
so so I want to challenge you today okay
I want to challenge you today I want to
challenge you today to start thinking
hey wait a minute am I even a top
producer three things you got to know
about money and the same three rules
hold true for attention number one you
got to get it you don't need to make it
it's already been made there's trillions
and trillions of dollars there's more
money on this planet than there are
iPhones okay endless supply
okay it's like it's garbage by the way
you need to understand it's garbage
once I get it the thing to do is once I
get it now I don't want to lose it how
do I not lose it I take it and I convert
it to something more valuable than money
so as fast as I can I'm gonna take this
cash that I earned I don't spend it ever
never spend this money no matter how big
the bag is I take the entire earned bag
and I dump it into something that
becomes that will produce passive income
for me the only thing I ever spend is
the hundred dollars that comes out of
the building not the bag that I earned
because of my talent I take my talents I
get paid for them I shift it into the
building the money goes away
money can't be lost now it's been
converted to concrete glass Steel
tenants leases
a real property okay it goes up in value
over time this gets destroyed over time
it can be get burnt it can get torn it
can get lost it can get uh stolen so I
want to get rid of this illiquid I want
to get illiquid in the building convert
it to something real and then I want to
wait when I get paid passive income this
passive income is not taxed it's only
taxed it's taxed up a small tiny
percentage of what earned income is so I
keep most of it and this is how I live I
live off of this money
and and I could spend all of this
or I could take this and start investing
in more buildings
the way you talk to me get it get it
keep it number two you got to keep it
how do I keep it I don't save it at the
bank when you put at the bank the bank
is going to tax it
cash is taxed all cash is taxed okay
cash is not King cash flow is king So
what you want is you want this you want
passive income and the third thing you
want to do is you want to figure out how
I can multiply that building will
multiply over time
there's nobody's going to tell me that
building will not be more money right
location
like like the cities we're buying in
Austin Houston Dallas Orlando Tampa uh
the Carolinas Nashville Tennessee
Atlanta Georgia if you're going on fire
Savannah Georgia anything in the in the
smiley part of the United States where
New York when the vaccine when they came
out last night and said hey we're
mandating I got calls from three buddies
I'm [ __ ] done with New York
I thought they were going to change
they're not New York is going to feed
that building 20 of our tenants right
now are from New York City
10 percent are from California moving
from La all the way over to Miami
so people are tired of the [ __ ] man
and and and and when they're tired of
that what they do is they move and when
they move they rent first they don't buy
first you better get excited now because
if you're not going to get excited now
nobody will give you this money
nobody will give you this money Money
Follows attention how much attention can
I get in the marketplace is where money
goes money does not go to the best
product ever money does not go to the
best product money does not go to the
happiest place either money goes to
where attention goes whoever gets the
most attention gets the most money
action Massive Action has always worked
it's proven itself for thousands of
years this is not a New Concept
you show me somebody and we know their
name anybody anybody in the in the in
the room any famous person
that you can think of
anybody that we would both know you say
I'm going to mention their name and
Grant will know who that is give me a
name of one person Massive Action
persistent Massive Action okay
okay how many people were watching the
open yesterday
yeah exactly why
because tiger was in it attention Money
Follows attention
Money Follows attention how much
attention can you even bad attention
okay I'm gonna tell you something
what tiger went through in the last
decade helped him
you got more white people pulling for
Tiger Woods
right they're like tiger grown white and
tiger and we say there's division in
this country tiger I love tiger right
why because they love a comeback man the
guy got a lot of attention Okay who else
give me another name
oh my God I didn't I didn't know it was
going to be this kind of meeting
if I didn't know this could be this kind
of me I'd charge a double
check Donald Trump everybody knows you
okay Money Follows attention success and
power follow attention Okay you cannot
like the guy but could you handle
that much heat
every day
could you handle that many people not
liking you every day
because if you're going to be a leader
if you're going to be a real leader okay
if you're going to be at the top of the
food chain kind of leader people aren't
going to like you money is garbage
it's garbage it's not it's not really
what you want because it gets taxed
heavily
so and this is another thing the ball
players don't understand this most the
middle class doesn't understand it the
guy making 50 racks a year done the guy
making 500 racks a year doesn't
understand it guy working at Facebook
doesn't understand he knows how to code
he don't know how to beat the tax man
and the way to beat the tax man is with
real estate it is the last venue where
and I'm not talking about a house
I'm talking about buying like this piece
of real estate right behind me right
dust that piece of real estate is 260
million dollars
now I didn't start with that my first
deal was my first deal was a three
million dollar deal I made 5 million on
it one deal
and paid no taxes and when I did that
first deal man I did I put 350 Grand
down I borrowed it from my mom and a
brother
uh and made five I turned 350 Grand into
five million dollars and didn't have to
go through the [ __ ] that I was going
through every single day
and I'm like oh my God this is a game
man when I went to file my taxes the guy
showed me how not to pay taxes on it I'm
like okay I'm good
and I've been doing that I now have four
billion dollars worth of real estate I
started with 300 Grand borrowed money I
got four billion dollars this deal right
here is a quarter of a billion
and what I've learned over the last 25
years is this game is on it's on it's a
rigged game and it's on stack
it's all it's all stacked against the
little guy in the middle guy
and so what I decided to do was was I
promised my mom when I was 15 years old
Dorian I said if I ever make it I'm
gonna help the little guy out
because I grew up with a single mother
five kids she was freaking frightened
all that she never got a shot at that
stuff
you know if my family got to buy a house
that they had we had you got to pay for
if we could buy a house and pay it off
that was freaking like that was the
American dream
that ain't a dream bro that's prison
that right there behind me cash flow day
one
trophy asset
appreciation two and three and four
times most of this real estate's been
doubling every every decade
uh trophy institutional quality great
write-offs everything the wealthy look
for in an investment so I'm buying this
deal and then I open it up to my friends
and followers on Facebook Instagram Tick
Tock thousand dollars
with a thousand dollars you can partner
with me in that deal
and it's important for everybody to know
like oh my God this guy's gonna raise
money from everybody I could have gotten
one company One bank would have given me
the entire
amount of money that I'm raising for my
friends
One One bank said hey I'll give you the
whole two I'll give you all the money
for the deal and you you'd be the
partner in the deal Grant you run the
deal will be the money and I didn't take
the money because I want my friends my
followers the people on this I want to
give people a shot
so uh because you're you're easier to
deal with Dorian I'd rather you be my
partner in the deal than Bank of America
in the beginning when you go to a new
land a new place or a new planet you
have to make investments in in the
environment and hope that hey if I keep
doing this if I keep making these
deposits
whether it's me going to the gym I don't
know if the gym worked for me this
morning I know if I can stack up enough
gym visits
if I go to church enough
hey man maybe some of it'll rub off on
me I'll become a good guy one day okay
if if I make enough investments in
people and human beings and talking to
people we were out here shooting some
video today and I'm like hey how you
guys doing how you guys doing how you
guys the only reason I'm doing that is
to make investments in people because if
I do that often enough
um I'm practicing one you know
extroverting myself to communicate to
people because everything that I want
everything that's going to be good in my
life is going to come through other
people it's not going to come because I
sat in a room by myself it's gonna
become my wife and I and Michael and we
went out into the marketplace and
actually moved some people around like
you're coming to my event now right yeah
we are yeah exactly see what you become
is what you will be
most people are sitting in the student
chair too long you're learning you like
learning studying reading you know
trying to get information dude the way
to the way to trick the system is to
become something as fast as possible
don't keep learning buy something this
is the easiest simplest way for somebody
to become an investor I did the deal I
bought the deal with my money did the
research with my money my time my energy
my 30 years I use my cred with the banks
and the real estate Community to get the
deal that deals 260 million dollars your
entire audience could not buy that deal
by itself even if it had the money
because it doesn't have the connection
yep so I'm paying I'm buying the deal
with my money and my bank of my my debt
then once I buy it and closed it I've
taken all this risk out
because once I buy it and close it then
I offer it up to my audience and say
same price that I paid you can get in at
one thousand dollars five thousand ten
thousand whatever number you're
comfortable with
so what happens is one your money's
protected against inflation and
deflation okay against the disruption
and destruction of the dollar which is
what what's happening right now is they
are purposely destroying the dollar the
very thing they told you for the last 30
years you should save and you should you
should you know trade your most valuable
asset for they are now destroying the
very thing that you've been saving
and they're penalizing you for having it
because they pay you nothing to keep it
understand that that a thousand I'm
gonna answer your whole question here
understand that a thousand dollars today
at Bank of America or Wells Fargo
let me see a thousand dollars today
times pays one dollar and twenty cents
[ __ ]
let me see yeah that's 1.20 anyway crazy
okay now that's before you bought your
checks that's before you started the the
checking account that's before you use
the ATM by the time the end of the year
is your thousand dollars probably more
like 920 bucks probably cost you 80
bucks just to have a checking account
so number one you become an investor
number two you get cash flow every
quarter number three I expect that
building to be a double or a triple so
I'm paying 260 for the building if I
sell it for 340 we make a double
I think the building is going to sell
for 500 million when I sell it
location is ridiculous can't replace it
it's 99 occupied right now it's a trophy
quality asset it's in Fort Lauderdale
Florida one of the hottest markets in
the country and when I sell this I will
be selling it to an institution and the
reason that's important is because most
of us that are earning 50 bucks a night
you have to buy The Leftovers man you
know the the we're buying leftovers
we're buying we're buying the garbage in
the community the duplex the single
family home these are the same homes
that went back to the banks in 2010 and
you don't want to be in that stuff what
you want to be is the trophy stuff that
somebody always finds value in yeah so I
think the return is uh five to six
percent in the first year paid out
quarterly
uh we passed through the depreciation to
you so you won't be paying taxes for the
first couple of years on your income
um and I think you get a double or
triple uh off your money so if you put
in 10 grand I think you're looking at
your money being 20 or 30 000 over the
next uh five six seven years I want my
employees to stay broke
no one employs sitting with cash cash
means Porsches
Porsches me he's going to be in trouble
every person I've ever seen work for me
that does this stuff before they get
their Investments right they go buy junk
H belts big watches they can't afford
the new one the the a real Hublot so
they go buy a big you know eighty dollar
watch dude when you start seeing
indicators of that people start playing
all that stuff they're doing bottle
service over at live on the weekends
acting like free money will end up at
Lyft so Steve Steve when you came to
work for me how much money were you
making
three thousand dollars a month three
grand a month okay you can't live on
three grand a month in Miami every day
we would tell them you cannot live on
three grand a month in Miami it's
impossible just tell them so it's
impossible so re tell people the truth
is it the truth
can you live on three thousand dollars
in any city in America
not without fear
you can live on it but not without fear
and that's what you need to tell your
people folks you need to leave here if
you want your people all on the same
page how many like to have everybody
highly motivated say hey
how many you like to have everybody
around you really engaged how many of
you like to be surrounded by friends
that are actually talking about
hey let's all do better rather than make
sense of how they're doing
okay how many of you'd like to pay for
the fuel in my plane for us to go
someplace
but you can't
and that's a damn shame
okay like that that's that should be
your goal hey I want Grant to pick me up
are you going to pick me up in your
plane
like think that big folks think that big
get people around you thinking that big
all right when you go to dinner don't
worry about hey guys okay uh let's all
throw the card in
really
you should be fighting to pay for the
[Music]
pay for this every business I have five
companies now we'll do a hundred million
this year I started every one of those
companies with no money zero money man
just
just
I've called on people I didn't want to
be with I've done things I didn't want
to do okay it is not about doing what
you love it's about doing whatever it
takes to make your dreams a reality to
be closed and stay closed if you if you
closed on your product if you're not
buying your own product why would you
expect anybody else to
400 bucks is a lot of money your
prospect says to you four hundred
dollars do it
listen to me man you're 32 years old
you've been trying to save money for 20
years and you had do it and do it now I
don't need anything special here I'm not
going to be empathetic it quit being
stupid right to check
foreign
guy likes that or not but I know this
look if you believe in what you're
selling how many of you believe in what
you're selling thank
you then close the deal okay learn to
close and you'll never be without work
you'll never be without money you'll
have an organization that is booming in
affluence
pipeline full you'll have appointments
filled up right I call it a a group
called me yesterday I'm actually trying
to do a deal with CNBC in the guy says
I'm interested I said good I'll be there
tomorrow call me back I'll be I'm flying
into New York tomorrow what am I trying
to do right now by the way I was
supposed to be here
flying to New York tomorrow I can be
there tomorrow Mr Ackerman okay how does
that work
I can't do tomorrow
figure out how to be in two
times later
right you some of you in the room are
like hey I could see you at four o'clock
on Tuesday right and the customer says
to you I'll see you at 4 foreign
you're so busy
dude that is so old
that is so old and it's dishonest
dishonest man
you want to see me until you see four
o'clock I give you Tuesday at four
o'clock
done
I'll call you if something changes if
there's an earthquake between now and
next Tuesday Tuesday morning there's a
massive earthquake and I can't be there
you think everybody will understand
commit first they're going to rest out
later close the deal right now fill your
calendar up your Calendar's got the
devil all over it
white space on a calendar and you will
meet the devil
don't need to die okay you go two or
three days without anything going on how
many of you start having doubts you're
in hell
oh my God this evening
there's nobody coming in I'm not gonna
hit my target okay I know what I'll do
I'll lower my targets
never lower a Target
never lower a Target never lower a
Target your mom and dad would tell you
to lower a target a manager might tell
you to lower Target be reasonable
foreign
no man criminal products are created
like that
he's the girl that he wants that's the
girl
girl she says no he goes to another girl
gave up on his dream
if you're gonna give up in your own
dream how are you going to build an
organization you will never ever
experience great change in your life
unless you're willing to give up
something that you have right now
every single time in my life I have had
to give up something I wanted so I'm not
talking about getting rid of the bad
stuff you got to get rid of something
that you actually work for to get
might have been the house it might have
been oh my kids are in the best schools
now it's going to be something painful
for you to get to the next place you
have to give up something that you
worked for really really hard so I sold
my house one day I had this cognition
hey to get what you want you have to
give up what you have
that has been true for me throughout my
entire life I had to leave Lake Charles
Louisiana went to Houston had to leave
Houston once I got comfortable with my
community and my friends had to leave
San Diego had to go to La La is a pit
compared to La Jolla nobody goes from La
Jolla California up to Los Angeles
nobody does that
Kansas City to go to Los Angeles
because you want to be an actor I met
Elena within five minutes of arriving in
LA
all right
I sold my house I sold my house I didn't
leave it vacant as a backup plan I left
this house okay like I couldn't buy this
house today if I wanted to it was so
like it was a precious little treasure
I had to give that up by the way I had
to give up being the mayor of my little
town everybody knew me it wasn't a
restaurant I couldn't walk into I could
always get a seat I could always get the
best seat I had it right in my hand this
is what I'm telling you guys you have to
be willing to give something up and the
moment you do you better have your
partner on your side
whoever's in your life mom whoever's the
big influence that significant other
person in your life that you're going to
consult that everybody's going to
consult every one of you are going to
hey what do you think should I
you better have that person on your side
in my case I was by myself
so my consultant was like you gonna do
this dog I called my buddy dale dale you
think I should he's like you're
miserable bro you got everything you
want and you're miserable
he's like what do you have to risk sold
the house went to Los Angeles lived in a
hotel I went from a house on the ocean
to living in a hotel the hotel room was
probably like I don't know maybe the
size of this stage so please please do
whatever you got to do this weekend to
figure out whatever you got to do to get
rid of whatever is holding you back most
of which is something you worked hard to
get
okay maybe before the weekend's over you
could write down two or three or four
things you worked really hard to get
that you think you're supposed to keep
you got them already you got it you
already did that you don't have to keep
it the problem was I was not I do what a
lot of entrepreneurs do
the mistake a lot of entrepreneurs make
is number one they never look up the
definition entrepreneur
an entrepreneur means someone is who
organizes a business or businesses and
invests money takes greater than normal
risk with money in order to expand or
organize those businesses
I wasn't spending money on my business
like all I was doing was knocking on
doors it was just pure effort I wasn't
spending money like
I wouldn't spend real money until I was
50 50 or so about 10 years ago when it
when a guy said bro you're not a
business
and I said what he and I could feel this
yeah I was a hustler I was a grinder
but I wasn't a business and I and I
could feel it you know uh yeah I was a
consultant I could I was making some
money like in my 30s and 40s I made you
know I made a lot of money what what
other people would call a lot of money
yeah but I was not a business you know
what I mean I was just what do you mean
by that well I was just hustling
everything was the transaction yeah
everything everything was a transaction
to get money pay the taxes have a little
bit of money left over everything was in
a transaction yeah and um and this guy's
like well you know you're not a business
and I was like I know man I know don't
tell anybody I know that okay like I
knew it and because because to me a
business is I can walk away from it
it'll still operate
I was I was a guy I was no different
than when I was 30 just pounding doors
and which was good which was good and I
think a lot of people need to you don't
need to skip that spot either
because once I put the two together okay
I can pound the door I can learn
e-commerce
um I can be I can be a one product sale
I could sell to companies like today
we'll sell we'll sell a product to a
company for 80 grand on a three to five
year contract 80 grand a year
and I'll switch immediately and sell an
eight dollar product online or I'll give
something away for free
to speaking to 4 000 people today in
hopes that I can meet
you know maybe 40 of them that I can do
have a partnership and a collaboration
with in the future this is the taboo
thing to say it's never going to be on
tv nobody likes you got to have money
nobody's nobody ever says this yeah oh
yeah I do this I do that I have that
dude you got to have money you can't you
can't
you know what do I mean by that like
okay well like create the life you want
yeah quit saving money
you know quit buying watches and H belts
like I don't have an Hermes belt like I
don't even know how to pronounce Hermes
I'm like well who would spend seven 800
bucks on a belt like like I could buy
three thousand dollars but the real
estate with a 700 bill right and who am
I trying to impress anyway what I need
is I need a trainer to come to me so you
buy your armies belt I'm gonna buy a
trainer to come to me I don't want to go
to him
okay I know time is money
it's not money a sign it's time is money
so why am I going to get a car and drive
to to to to the trainer
here I'll give you another 200 bucks you
come to me
okay you come to me I walk down there I
do my workout boom I'm done well he's
he's still driving 40 minutes
and I'm already taking a shower and and
doing a business deal
so you got to figure out the things in
your life
you know when I when I when I went from
okay I'm never gonna do I'm never going
to work for below my pay grade anymore
like this was a big shift for me
like I like gardening I like landscape
stuff right when I got rid of a yard I
was like that was that that probably
made me 10 million bucks
I loved it I spent too much time doing
it it was costing me money it was below
my pay grade
you know you see what I'm saying like
what am I doing what am I doing like oh
because it's therapeutic well good man
like like not two hours of it it's
Therapeutics cost you millions of
dollars because you're out there playing
with stuff that made me feel good and
everything but there's got to be a
faster better way to do that to get that
sensation you know this concept of time
management has been pushed off on me my
entire life and I have never ever agreed
with it I'm like why would I want to
manage time
what am I going to do how do you manage
time what do I do I like okay I'm gonna
watch these seconds dude I don't want to
manage time I want to produce I want to
be highly productive I want to squeeze
time I literally want to take time and I
want to turn 60 minutes into three hours
of production that's the different think
that you need today not manage time now
there are some tricks when managing time
if that's where you want to come from
like Alan Greenspan Alan Greenspan and
his roommate in college his roommate's
father taught Alan Greenspan a little
trick that Alan Greenspan used his whole
life and it was to break up the day into
15 minute blocks 15 minutes I have
something and then fill up the next 15
minutes now the reason Alan did that and
I like that concept A lot is because he
didn't want white space on that calendar
he knew white space was a problem
because white space nothing in the 15
minutes is a waste of time
see before you start thinking about just
managing time first I want you to do
this number one I want you to make a
list of things that you're doing every
day that is a waste of time that is the
way you create time not manage it the
first thing I want to do is look at
things that I'm doing that are wasteful
those two or three hours a day that are
wasteful moments things I'm doing on
Facebook that just are waste of time or
maybe a game I'm playing that's a waste
of time or maybe a newspaper I'm reading
where I'm not really learning anything
I'm reading about the the celebrities
it's a waste of time okay second thing I
want you to do is this I want you to
then start thinking about these 15
minute blocks and filling that calendar
up but the third and most important
thing I want you to think about is how
can you create time how can you
literally take 24 hours and and pack
more into it so that you can become more
productive so that you can use that
urgency concept and really blow up your
your career blow up your life make the
most incredible life for your family for
you for the kids for your wife or your
husband and for your clients so that you
can take care of yourself materially as
well 12 years ago we had done maybe I
don't know 20 million dollars over the
internet
we'd run over a billion dollars in sales
over the internet in the last 12 years
okay
thank you
[Music]
like you guys got to learn how to use
enthusiasm like when you use it use it
like the more you use the more you get
you're like I'ma save my energy now and
I want to give him too big a hand too
early it's really early today come on
look man with somebody successful you
ought to throw down that's what I'm
talking about
see you guys you guys got it y'all got
y'all gotta quit trying little tricks
and gimmicks like if you gotta walk on
fire to get excited you are ramped up
like like if you can't at will whenever
you want to for any reason just get
excited
then you got a problem okay because in
real in the real world you can't you
can't be in the middle of a meeting and
I'm trying to get her to give me like a
hundred million dollars and I'm not I'm
feeling a little depressed or bad right
now or I got my attention on my kids and
and I'm like okay
[Music]
everybody's gonna be like nah we were
gonna give you the hundred until you
started pumping your chest
right you can't say hang on a second man
I got to go into a state change like
that's not real you guys understand you
have to be able to that's a gimmick
and gimmicks take time okay and gimmicks
cannot be duplicated what can be
duplicated or disciplines
and that's what you're going to we're
going to be sharing with you over the
next three days disciplines can be
duplicated if you've seen my children
okay if you bet how many of you've seen
Sabrina and Scarlett those are
disciplines
okay if they were in here right now they
could get on that stage and talk to you
they know how to look you in the eyes
they know how to shake your hand because
they have been taught how to communicate
we spend less time on teaching them how
to count than we do communicate
connect with people okay we have them
homeschooled The Homeschool teacher what
do you want to learn you just keep
teaching them what I'm teaching them you
teach them confidence you teach
employees you teach them the ability to
communicate be dangerous not careful
okay we teach our kids how to be
dangerous I teach my kids how to meet
strangers and greet strangers we teach
our kids that strangers have everything
they want and strangers are not
dangerous
okay is there danger in the society yeah
that's what those guys are for over
there
so I'm gonna put my kids in environment
where they can meet 99 of the people and
feel safe to meet them talk to them
communicate with them so I want to make
sure that my kids can walk into an
environment and have zero concern about
him her or him
and they can walk out and say Hey I want
to meet you because strangers have
everything that you want
the people you don't know and haven't
met These Guys these guys dressed in
their robes what do you call the robes
the Condor okay I have one in my closet
by the way I love the Condor I put the
Condor on one time and I was like I'm a
bad bad man
dude I felt so freaking powerful it was
amazing okay I grew a beard I'm like now
I'm a man okay give me a camel
okay it was like it was like phenomenal
right like but but you you guys need to
have that kind of Swag everywhere in
life and regardless of how old you are
25 and you're like I'm too young to have
swag or 55 and now you're too old it's
not true you just need to get the
confidence that a Bravado not fake it
you don't need to fake it you need to
you need to get you need to get
confidence if I could get rid of this
right here in life if I could get rid of
these Downs man how confident would I be
I mean like I'm going into every deal
I'm gonna win
and that is possible folks okay but it
starts with who knows me
because if I'm walking around this
planet and nobody knows me I'm going to
be terrified one thing that I've done
since I was 25 years old is learn how to
set goals
put them in place and then manifest them
over periods of time in my lifetime if
you go back and listen to the rules of
success that I shot that show in I think
I was 4 35 years old 36 years old in La
Jolla California I was living on the
ocean then and
you can go back to that you can look in
the 10x rule when I wrote the 10x rule I
shared a bunch of goals that was 11
years ago you could see over the last 25
years every single goal that I have set
for myself up to this point anyway I
have been able to achieve my wife my two
beautiful kids the condition that my
body's in today my finances the real
estate all of it started with goals all
of it started with the idea that was in
my mind and had not yet been manifested
in reality
I heard a saying once uh Barbra
Streisand said that there was not one
thing in her career that she had
accomplished tips on Ronnie goals number
one write them down every day in fact
what I do is I write mine down on a
blank sheet of paper
I write them down in the am I write them
down in the PM and I also write them
down anytime I'm disappointed or
discouraged
okay so I could actually write my goals
down more than twice a day always in the
am always in the PM first thing I do in
the morning first thing I did today
was I wrote my goals down second thing
what I'll do before I go to sleep
tonight is write my goals down it could
be on the same legal pad second thing I
write them down in present tense
in PT
present tense or even past tense
are passed okay so I may write it as
though I have accomplished it what you
don't want to do is write it down one
day I will love my job okay you want to
write down I love my job even if you
hate your job right now just like flip
it I love my job okay I Love My Wife and
Kids I didn't have a wife and kids
uh my kids love me I didn't have any
children okay I wrote it down as though
it was happening okay
um
write your goals down whether or not
you're achieving them or not it doesn't
matter that you're achieving them okay
this is going to sound a bit like you're
deceiving yourself which is what you're
doing you're you're writing down the
future as though it's happening today
and or has happened number four strongly
suggest that you go ten times bigger on
your goals than you think what is
accomplishable okay I say go big or
go bigger baby
okay go big or go bigger there is
nothing wrong with big think
it doesn't cost anything okay you can't
get taxed for thinking big
and it's not just okay I'm a dream big
and big things are going to happen okay
I am going to write down hey I'm trying
to achieve X in my life I'm trying to go
from here to 10 times bigger than I can
think okay during the day I'm going to
take the actions that support that when
I write this down every day number five
do not be disappointed
in not achieving just keep writing
just because you're not hitting it just
keep writing it I wrote down off and on
from time to time I wrote down for years
saving money in a bank account is
ridiculous the only people that benefit
is the bank
so what do you do with the money then
you you use money first thing people
should invest in is themselves look you
know best thing is people hear that and
they go what does that mean though what
do I do with the money go to go to
workshops go to seminars go to whatever
you're good at whatever you're doing
you're an astronaut invest in yourself
if you're an athlete invest in yourself
don't spend money on belts yeah and
looking good like invest in your craft
you're a comedian invest in your craft
and that means investing in your skills
uh uh uh coach uh uh whatever whatever
podcasts yeah whatever needs to get you
known right and and then also in in your
branding and your marketing like people
have to know you no matter how good you
are if I don't know you it doesn't
matter right so you got to get out there
yeah how did how did you guys run into
me had I run into you yeah how did you
find out about Instagram good I invested
a lot of money making sure that people
see that Instagram account right right
so our energy money and energy right so
uh invest in yourself first
to become great at whatever you're doing
number two start investing in your
business
if that if you hadn't done that already
and the third thing is start investing
in things that will pay you every month
so you buy you buy a flow of income this
idea that it takes money to make money
is not true it's a myth it's it's it's
the number one reason why I did the show
The Discovery show to debunk that on TV
that I didn't need any money at all uh
they offered me 100 bucks I'm like just
keep it dude like no no we got to give
it to you it's part of the show and I'm
like I don't need the hundred they're
like no but you got to take the 100 as
part of the show the entire 90 days I
never touched the first hundred they
gave me and this was to prove to people
do you do not need money like it's just
it's not true you need money you do need
contacts you need people you need these
people you need people you need the
right people though
the right people that are already in
play okay just because the guy's got
money
I remember a a billionaire friend of
mine uh you know he could buy a jet
and I said hey Bob should I buy a jet he
said you should I shouldn't
meaning Grant should because and he's
way wealthier than I am he could have
about 40 of them he's like I don't have
a place to go in mine you have a you
could use yours every day so you you got
to find somebody that's in place
somebody that not just has money but
somebody that wants to do more with
their money
so you'll notice in the first uh 10 days
I don't spend any money I don't spend
money on shelter not on food and not on
water nothing then what I do is I end up
accumulating assets and it's unfortunate
that the viewer doesn't see this within
five days I have two vehicles one was
given to me by Discovery and the other
one was a forty thousand dollar Jeep
that I basically used
uh from Brian this guy I met and told
him I'm gonna sell your Jeep I'm going
to drive it around town and put 10 miles
a day on it and I'm gonna sell it well
that's a forty three thousand dollar
asset uh my truck was worth four grand I
still had my hundred dollars I lived in
a forty six thousand dollar RV that I
was trying to sell so yeah uh and what's
the other thing I did and I picked up
ten thousand dollars
to do in a 15 partnership in the equity
of the upside of this guy's company so
literally in 10 days I was accumulating
contacts that could get me equity in the
in the important part of that story is
man go get you some equity
you know Jay-Z talks about this you're
getting you know so many of you young
brothers are getting in advance while
I'm picking up the equity last thing I'm
gonna tell you is this okay
don't
don't get stuck in mechanics
when I'm writing my goals down I do not
know how I'm going to do it
so I merely sit down like I remember for
years I would write down I own a
helicopter I don't even know where this
concept came from I'm on a helicopter I
own a helicopter I own a helicopter
every once in a while it would show up
it would show up on a Wednesday and not
show up for uh when I'm writing my goals
down right so I'm waking up in the
morning I wake up in the morning I write
my goals down and one day I write I own
a helicopter
I think back then it was uh I learned
how to fly a helicopter okay it was
stupid it was completely ridiculous I'm
like where did that come from it just
kind of floated into my mind I wrote it
down okay I own a jet
I'm like man I'm just being stupid right
now I own a jet and two helicopters
I don't know how that happened I didn't
I didn't know anything about Jets I
would not achieve any of this by the way
until I was 50
53 years old 54 years old
first private jet I was ever on was the
one uh we bought
I I didn't know anything about it I
didn't know how they fly I didn't know
how they work I didn't know what the
cost of a hanger was I know nothing
don't get lost in the mechanics I didn't
know the fuel cost I didn't know what it
cost to buy one do you finance them do
you pay cash do you get a tax rate I
knew nothing when I started writing this
down the helicopter would come after the
jet okay I bought a helicopter I didn't
know why
so the point of that story is when
you're writing your goals down literally
sit down with a blank sheet of paper
first thing you wake up in the morning
and you just start Zip Zip Zip Zip you
write through them like this morning I
wrote down 40 billion in real estate
okay public I write down one word I'm
going public
see I know now that this this is in
present tense and or past tense I write
it in present or past tense I'm going
public okay I wrote down recently uh uh
Congressional hearing
people like what's a congressional
hearing dude I'm so big now they called
me into Congress
they're going to have a congressional
hearing they're going to drill me okay
oh yeah then I wrote this down a
political office
foreign
I don't know why I'm writing that down I
don't know how to achieve that I don't
know what it would mean I don't know
what it looks like I don't get stuck in
the mechanics don't worry about it first
commit first man just keep committing it
keep fueling and keep writing it down
eight billion people know my name how'd
you get started like what was your first
company what did it look like how did
all that happen my first company was
working for somebody else you know like
until it wasn't until I figured out how
to make somebody else Rich that I could
be rich like I hear a lot of guys saying
uh I don't want to work for somebody
else I don't want to keep making other
people when I became successful in
another company
and then left that company and went and
worked for another company and made them
super successful to the point to where
these companies were literally dependent
upon me like that that that's the thing
that's the muscle and the grit
persistence and fortitude are like you
know what I don't my ego wasn't like I
need my name on it but my ego was strong
enough to say I want to be the best
in the company like I want to make this
company dependent upon me the first
company the first real job I had was my
sixth job
I was fired from my first five fired
from my sixth job six times but wouldn't
leave the last one I just would not
leave so literally like I'd wrecked
stuff I I have a terrible driving record
and I was in the car business
and I'd wreck their cars and they'd fire
me and I say okay okay okay and then
before I would leave I would go sell
something and then they would keep me on
if selling something was always
forgiveness
so um
when I finally left that company they
went under like they could my production
was so high that one person leaving the
car company failed
went to my next job which was speaking
Consulting using my sales philosophies
and gifts if you will and we would go
around companies and teach them
and
I worked for him for 20 months I was
like the top guy in his company now the
reason I'm saying that is that was a job
for me and that was a business I treated
that little my little Department like
this is my company within a company
and and I wanted to make that company as
strong as possible so that when I made
when I finally went out on my own which
I was forced to go out of my own I
didn't want to go out of my own I went
out on my own just because there was
just no opportunity left
and there was no way for me to score
where I was
which I I still remember today it's
important to get good people to keep
them that like you got to give them some
other
Pond to to swim in
and so when I started my first company
uh I guess I was 29 that was a company
where I was cold calling on businesses
around the US and Canada three the third
thing the super successful do is they
Master income creation I was asked this
morning I left my home at four o'clock
in the morning I was on a plane at five
okay and a guy asked me he's like dude
why you still cranking so hard
because I don't have any money I'm
always broke I reinvest all the money
every time I get any money sitting in
accounts I take it and invest it in hard
assets
illiquid assets illiquid so that I
cannot get that money that's what keeps
me motivated folks
I get money liquid money
[Music]
if it's not use what
it's useless take it and I buy a hard
asset that produces income
I'm broke I gotta go hustle again here I
want to share with you the uh not so
secret way that thousands tens of
thousands actually millions of people
are becoming millionaires in America
today they invest in assets that
appreciate over time
invest in Assets in IPS that they
control
royalties they control things that they
know over time will increase in value
that there's a 99
99.9 percent chance that they're going
to increase in value and that's what
they invest in
they don't make little bets they make
big bets and they invest in things that
they know will go up in value over time
that could be a sports team uh chances
you buying a sports team are next to
none same for me
so you got to start thinking about okay
what assets can I do that with okay oh
wow I'm gonna go create I'm gonna go
create the next big thing
I'm going to create an app and
hundreds of millions of people are going
to download my app okay chance of you
doing that
uh your chances are bigger than mine
because I'm not even trying
there are assets out there today that
are in your backyard they're in your
neighborhood you don't have to buy a
sports team you don't need to be
connected you don't have to have a you
don't have to know how to write code or
do Tech it's sitting there waiting for
you right now and it's one of the ways
that I created the wealth that I have in
my life I have we have 11 businesses
today uh and and then we have a real
estate portfolio of 12 000 units going
to forty thousand units
and uh about four billion dollars worth
of real estate now the first the 11
businesses that I own and they were so
hard
to create him stardom manage them guide
them hire people for them advertise
Market get them known
like to organize it we have hundreds and
hundreds of employees in these companies
so about 700 employees across these
companies most of which are startups
they're brand new they don't have a lot
of employees a lot of risk a lot of
downside a lot of problems a lot of
headaches a lot of people the real
estate almost no headaches
compared to the value of the portfolio
very few people work at it it
appreciates the value over long periods
of time and that's what wealthy people
do they invest in assets real estate is
one of the things they love the first
three years I was in business I made
thirty thousand dollars a year
three years fish three years the first
the the last year I left somebody I was
making 150 160 Grand a year
the first maybe 27 months that I was in
business I made less than 30 000 a year
I went backwards
but the the problem was I was not I do
what a lot of entrepreneurs do
the mistake a lot of entrepreneurs make
is number one they never look up the
definition entrepreneur
an entrepreneur means someone is who
organizes a business or businesses and
invests money takes greater than normal
risk with money in order to expand or
organize those businesses
I wasn't spending money on my business
like all I was doing was knocking on
doors it was just pure effort I wasn't
spending money like
I wouldn't spend real money until I was
50 50 or so about 10 years ago when it
when a guy said bro you're not a
business
and I said what he and I can feel this
yeah I was a hustler I was a grinder
but I wasn't a business and I and I
could feel it you know uh yeah I was a
consultant I could I was making some
money like in my 30s and 40s I made you
know I made a lot of money what other
people would call a lot of money yeah
but I was not a business you know what I
mean I was just what do you mean by that
well I was just hustling
everything was the transaction yeah
everything everything was a transaction
to get money pay the taxes have a little
bit of money left over everything was in
a transaction yeah and
um and this guy's like well you know
you're not a business
I was like I know man I know don't tell
anybody I know that okay like I knew it
and because because to me a business is
I can walk away from it it'll still
operate
I was I was a guy I was no different
than when I was 30 just pounding doors
and which was good which was good and I
think a lot of people need to you don't
need to skip that spot either
because once I put the two together okay
I can pound the door I can learn
e-commerce
uh I can be I can be a one product sale
I could sell it to companies like today
we'll sell we'll sell a product to a
company for 80 grand on a on a three to
five year contract 80 grand a year
and I'll switch immediately and sell an
eight dollar product online or I'll give
something away for free
to speaking to 4 000 people today in
hopes that I can meet
you know maybe 40 of them that I can do
have a partnership and a collaboration
with in the future invest in assets to
cash flow give me a drip let me rip
give me a little drip
give me something every month give me
something every quarter give me
something to reward me three percent
four percent ten percent give me
something to reward me to have a 10x Big
Bang at the end of the appreciation of
the asset Warren Buffett says three
rules don't lose money two don't
remember number one don't lose money and
number three only invest in things at
cash flow you know Warren Buffett he's
got he's a major player in uh at Apple
now and it took him forever to get there
and the reason he finally invested in
apple was because he understood finally
understood the cash flow of the iTunes
account
it was crazy that's when he made his big
move every company he's ever invested in
had positive cash flow be a better guy
man I mean you know just be a good guy
and be be
you know the thing I'm proud of is I get
to be Grant all the time you know I'm
actually getting to the point where I'm
like hey man I finally got to be what I
I finally
became what I wanted to be what was that
me yeah
you know that I don't have to apologize
anymore that I couldn't screwing up and
I quit having to call people and say hey
man I I said I went too far you know if
I could just pull some of that back
without that drug that that psychiatrist
was trying to use right you know that if
I'm less dependent upon
aggression you know and I could I could
kind of manifest more you know like you
you talk about better let it flow more
Let it Flow dude let it flow you know
but
but if I could get that perfect balance
of aggression and flow that's a sweet
spot yeah it's sweet dude it's hard to
find that thing same spot you know to be
that
I don't want to be I don't want to be
the little stream that drips you know I
want to be like but I don't want to
damage anybody right I don't want to
hurt anybody you know I don't want to I
don't want to be in competition anymore
but I also don't want to lose the edge
right you know it's a dance dude it's a
dance dance you know like like your girl
said to me the other night she's like
she said something before she left she's
like I really get who you are you know
that and that hits me when people say
that to me most people don't get who I
am that's beautiful you know and then
she said I really get who you are yeah
and and a lot of people don't yeah and
it sometimes it hurts right because I
know who I really am yeah and but I also
know the things I'm trying to accomplish
for me you know like Ryan Ryan gets who
I am you know Ryan Ryan never takes me
on man you're you're the best Queen
you're the best he just he Strokes me
right right through it and and and you
know my wife I can see my wife she gets
she gets tired of the the pounding you
know but hey man I just you know I'm a
right-handed hitter you know or I got I
got a certain ball that I throw a
certain shot I make and yeah it's my
go-to you know and when when I get
threatened I'm gonna go to that
and if I could develop some other set of
skills you know that would be that would
be a cool thing the thing is
to be pop positive
for this no
need that I talk about the way to avoid
uh negative and distracting people man
is to vibrate at a rate so fast okay
that you're out in front of them once I
got a speeding ticket actually here in
Miami and the and the police officer
says why are you speeding why are you in
such a hurry I'm like dude I'm trying to
stay away from The Crazies
okay if I can just get ahead of
everybody else I'm not distracted by
anybody but guys like you
and your job is to stop me but the truth
is their job is to stop me distract me
and cause me to turn around and and stop
my mission see so I got my ticket and
moved on and went to the head of the
pack again see this is what I'm telling
you man look if you want to not be
bogged down by negative distracted
people you need to take responsibility
that you're slowing down enough to get
caught up by this magnetic charge of
distractive and negative people dude you
need to vibrate so fast that these
people are distracting other people not
you get way ahead of the crowd get so
busy that nobody's gonna jack with you
man because you're filling up your
pipeline you're full you're busy and you
don't have this stuff sticking to you
look if you got negative people around
you if you got distracted people and we
all do but if it's causing you to be
distracted and negative dude you need to
vibrate you need to fill up your
pipeline you need to explode blow up get
busy so this isn't happening to you
because you're partly responsible
Platinum what are you willing to give up
you guys got to keep assessing the
situation and not be not be broad stroke
about it and say I'm not going to be a
dilettante or I'm going to be a
professional I'm going to I'm not gonna
no no but what are you gonna give up
there are times though again when I will
give up
that agreement
see like one of the things I have on
here being right you have to give up
being right
you know you can't can't want to be be
right and be successful they don't even
go together
impossible so again I'm willing to give
up being right I just gotta don't quit
man if you don't quit if you don't quit
you can't fail
it's impossible failure becomes
impossible for those that don't quit
it's impossible just think about it if I
keep moving towards the destination if I
if I'm if I'm going through the alphabet
A B C D E dude if you just keep going
all the way to Z you finish the alphabet
you break your leg along the way
somebody cut your tongue out you get
waterboarded you get a divorce you lose
your dad you lose a puppy
if you get to see you finish the
alphabet
period and boy when I heard that I'm
like God damn what was I thinking I was
thinking I could fail I can't fail if I
don't quit
so so that means I got to get rid I got
to dump people out of the car though
along the way right but we had to get
rid of a whole bunch of people
I I have to get rid of people how many
people have gone Johnny
I mean guys like if you saw the wreckage
like so many you don't see it you know
oh I'm not saying get rid of people I'm
just saying like like like what are you
willing to give up okay on my list I've
given up a house I've given up money I
gave up my retirement accounts I had
millions of dollars sitting in
retirement accounts I paid the penalty
to get the money
because it was a mistake years ago I got
convinced by the Banks to build an IRA
or 401K because I was trying to figure
out how to exit actually the people that
were giving me the advice were telling
me to figure out how to exit
you're planning an exit when you're 30
and it's stupid
think about what you're doing you're not
going to retire until you're 70. and the
rich people never worry about their
retirement accounts Warren Buffett has
not got a 401k he's got Coca-Cola
see the difference
see the difference in the think
okay so so like like you you guys have
to take a look at what you know that is
now a liability
what you know to be true that has become
a liability for you
and if you just study the middle class
of America study the entire structure of
the American economy you will see
you will see where a lot of these
liabilities exist that that are are
core values that you have not just for
you but for the entire population of
people
and and like if you just look at the
structure of America 311 million people
most of them are not doing well
you hear about it every day so the
solution is let's give everybody College
you know
let's give everybody coffee well College
could be one of the problems
look you know let's make sure everybody
gets through high school okay could be
one of the problems actually that it
takes 12 years to learn how to count
foreign
really so anyway I'm not saying I'm not
worried about trying to change all that
I'm just saying you might want to look
at how some of that has influenced you
you know the retirement accounts the
life insurance how many of you got life
insurance
how many of you got some cash value
sitting there some hope
dude get the money don't wait till you
die you need to unlearn some you need to
unlearn some stuff that Mom and Daddy
and your teacher told you your Mentor
your last guy whoever you're listening
to if what you have now hadn't got you
where you want to go what you have now
in your head might be keeping you from
where you want to go
okay math and money math and money how
old are you I'll be nine in three days
nine and three days okay math and money
so I'm Gonna Give You adding
Contracting you know how to do both of
those right yes and I'm gonna do
multiplying oh God okay now which of
these three are the most important when
it comes to money when it comes to money
let me show you one plus one or two two
plus one equals what three
2 minus 1 equals what one so we've got
three one two times
three equals what
wait that's simple
um two times three yes okay so which one
of these is the most powerful when it
comes to mine yes why would that be
because if you have if you know how to
multiply right and you have a dollar
right yeah and you can you're able to
multiply that into two dollars and you
can multiply that two dollars into
eighty hundred million thousand
we could get there faster right okay so
watch I'm gonna give you a little I'm
gonna give you a little drill here to
show you the power of multiplying add
add subtract correct multiply okay we're
going to use the same numbers every time
two plus two two plus two four two minus
two two minus two one oh wait that's
here
okay that's four
two plus two is four yeah
yeah two minus two is zero and two times
two two times two it's four let's do
this let's do this we're gonna do
another one because we love tens right
okay we're gonna take the number 10
because I have it on my hat
ten x a wait no now you have the number
10 on your hand okay ten and we're gonna
do ten plus
10.
10 minus 10. yeah yeah and 10 times 10
100 so so watch ten plus ten is how much
ten plus ten is twenty twenty ten minus
ten zero ten times ten one hundred now
we're using the same numbers but notice
the multiplier the number gets bigger a
lot faster than the other two yeah
so what'd you learn from this exercise
no we need to that if you multiply
subtracting doesn't help you subtract no
you gotta just get it okay okay no no
subtracting no reason to learn this in
school kids drug tests you know what you
know when people subtract stuff what
they're doing is they're like okay I'm
gonna go to the store and I'm gonna
spend this I'm gonna budget my money
they're using subtracting to determine
how much money they can spend if you add
it's obviously going to be less than
multiplying because multiplying you're
timesing the number so then it's
obviously more because like 10
plus two is gonna be twelve twelve but
ten times two ten times two is going to
be twenty so multiply it happens faster
because you're amazing so when it comes
to money you want to add subtract or
multiply you wanna multiply mainly and
then use the other two for pesky things
like stuff that's not needed you're
awesome buddy okay so now what I have to
do is I got to figure out how to go
multiply my friends and my money so I
can get Beyonce to come to the textbook
yes friends
you can multiply friends
so rather than adding one friend you
could add 10.
my friends multiply my money
good multiply my influence you know how
to spell influence l
multiply my power
and and help more people
hell because if I can maybe maybe I can
help Beyonce or Dolly Parton or who else
Adriana
Grande Ariana sorry I just remember her
by the ponytail okay maybe rainy Heine
can get Ariana
you like running with you okay all right
so okay if I can't get Beyonce and I
can't get a deal
and I can't get
I think Jimmy Fallon with that I can't
get a Ariana
Ariana okay and I can't get who else did
you want Dolly Parton Dolly Parton Jimmy
Fallon who else who else Kevin Hart
Kevin Hart I can get Kevin you can get
Kevin I believe in Kevin
I already had Kevin no I want Kevin
again you want Kevin again you love
Kevin huh Kevin's cool
um who else
I'm sorry Kevin okay who else you want
um what about the rock yes the rock okay
what about Jimmy Fallon can bring Ariana
Grande okay
um
I either want Beyonce or Adele okay one
of the other not both of them together I
mean yeah you can choose I mean I'll be
perfectly happy with all of them but
okay um and then Ariana wait I already
said it yeah and then Dolly Parton Dolly
Parton then I'll be happy okay I'll tell
you what I'm gonna invite one of those
people or more okay
but I need some huh and Kevin Hart do
you want Kevin Hart again yeah or maybe
he has shorty but look now we're best
friends
I want Zac Efron oh Zach you want Zac
Efron okay all right well you did your
math class so yeah I'm gonna see what I
can do today one or two of these people
okay okay
because you made it this far in the
video I want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you're different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all the way to the end and I love you so
as a special celebration if you put a
hashtag believe down in the comments
Below on this video I will showcase you
and celebrate you somewhere on the
screen in a future video because you are
awesome to get some incredible Ed mylett
motivation check the video right there
next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there when you get to winning for me
it's come down to maxing out and what
maxing out means is you do one more at
least than you think you're capable of
so when you're done whatever you're
doing whether it's at the gym